Hey, I'm Sean. And I'm Will. And I'm Jason. Hey, Will. Do you like golf? Oh, I love golf. Let's talk about golf. Ah, I hit a Ford.
嘿，我是肖恩。我是威尔。我是杰森。嘿，威尔。你喜欢高尔夫吗？哦，我太喜欢高尔夫了。我们来聊聊高尔夫吧。啊，我打中了一辆福特。
I hit it out of the park today on my Niner. Well, that's awesome. That's better than I. You guys, it's time to talk. We have to do a Smartless episode. Ah, Sean, shut the fuck up. Ah, yeah. What do you know?
我今天在我的九号杆上打出了一个全垒打。太棒了。比我打得好。伙计们，该聊正事了。我们得录一期Smartless。啊，肖恩，闭上你的臭嘴。啊，对。你知道什么？
Welcome to SmartLess. Shoney, are those classes new? Yeah, what do you think? Yeah, they're not bad. I mean... Let's go higher. Really? No, you don't like them? Well...
欢迎收看SmartLess。肖尼，这眼镜是新的吗？对啊，你觉得呢？对，还不错。我是说…… 抬高一点。真的吗？不，你不喜欢吗？呃……
Do you not like them seriously? I just put them on like five minutes ago. Lean closer to your camera. Do you like them? Oh, not that close. Yeah, another good. What do you think? Honestly.
你是认真的不喜欢吗？我大概五分钟前才戴上的。往摄像头靠近点。你喜欢吗？哦，没那么近。对，又一个不错的。你觉得呢？说实话。
You look great in everything. You know, I was noticing you on Kimmel last night. Me too. You looked great on Kimmel. I was thinking the same thing. All right. Are you working with a new stylist or something? I am actually.
你穿什么都好看。你知道，我昨晚注意到你在吉米秀上了。我也是。你在吉米秀上看起来太棒了。我也这么想。好吧。你是不是请了新的造型师什么的？其实是的。
Are you? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I can't dress myself like that. Shani, you look really good. Thanks, you guys. You did for real. It's true. Thank you.
是吗？对，对，对，对。我自己可搭不出这样的衣服。肖尼，你看起来真的很好。谢谢你们。你们是认真的。真的。谢谢。
Yeah, I, it's a, it's a, it's a, and you're a great guest. You're a very good guest. You are a great guest. You know, I don't know how you guys feel about talk shows and stuff. Like, I get so nervous. I talk fast. Well, that's, you know what's bad?
对，我，这是一个，这是一个，而且你是个很棒的嘉宾。你是个非常好的嘉宾。你是个很棒的嘉宾。你知道，我不知道你们对脱口秀之类的是怎么看的。比如，我总是觉得好紧张。我语速很快。嗯，那是，你知道什么很糟糕吗？
A guest that talks slow. Slow, right. Isn't nervous. Yeah. So, wait, Will, are you still in New York? I am, yeah. Wow. And it's still pressed for the movie?
语速慢的嘉宾。慢，对吧。不紧张。对。所以，等等，威尔，你还在纽约吗？在的，对。哇。还在为电影做宣传吗？
Still doing press for the movie. Yeah, still like just kind of getting going, really. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, because it comes out. It does it. Well, I don't know when this episode. December 19th is when the movie was out.
还在为电影做宣传。对，还在刚开始的阶段，真的。对。对。对，因为要上映了。确实要上映。好吧，我不知道这期节目是什么时候播出的。电影是12月19日上映的。
December 19th? Yeah, is this thing on. I can't wait for everybody to see you in it. It's so exciting. And what about you? You're in it too, Mr. And Sean, you're in it too. Sure.
12月19日？对，这玩意儿开着吗。我迫不及待想让大家看你在里面的表现了。太令人兴奋了。那你呢？你也在里面，先生。还有肖恩，你也在里面。当然。
Shawney was doing press for it last night. My favorite line I had in the movie is, does anybody want to play banana grams? Yeah. That's it. What I loved about it was your line, the way, the way, it was as if you had said that a million times. Yeah, by the way, totally.
肖尼昨晚还在为它做宣传呢。我在电影里最喜欢的一句台词是：“有人想玩香蕉拼词（bananagrams）吗？”对。就这样。我喜欢的是你的那句台词，那个语气，就好像你已经说过一百万遍了一样。对，顺便说一句，完全是。
I know. You know, we don't often do these records here in the mid-afternoon, here it is 3 p.m. here on the west coast, 6 p.m. there in the east. You got it. And, you know, listen, I think the audience is aware that the three of us are not in our 20s, okay? What? Well, I just what do I want to say is, I get a little tie-tie right now. At three?
我知道。你知道，我们不经常在下午中期录音，现在是西海岸时间下午3点，东海岸那边是下午6点。没错。而且，你知道，听着，我想观众也知道我们三个已经不是二十多岁的人了，对吧？什么？好吧，我只想说的是，我现在有点困了。三点？
This is not an ideal time for us to be doing. Well, you've got to find it. Well, hey, listen, save it, okay, nappy poo. How do you guys get through the late afternoon, okay? Sean, I've already explained your strategy. Will, how do you do it? You know, I just do stuff, you know, whatever. Schnitzy Leroux.
这对我们来说并不是录音的理想时间。好吧，你得克服它。好吧，听着，省省吧，小宝宝。你们下午是怎么熬过来的，对吧？肖恩，我已经解释过你的策略了。威尔，你是怎么做到的？你知道，我就是做做事情，你知道，随便什么。施尼齐·勒鲁。
Or do you guys go to like an espresso at a certain time every day? No, I do, I do not. What are you waving at? There's a fly in here, Doc, on it? Like an old gramp? Like the guy from up. He's an old man.
还是说你们每天到某个特定时间会去喝杯浓缩咖啡？不，我没有，我才不喝。你在向什么挥手？这里有只苍蝇，天哪，真的假的？像个老头子？就像《飞屋环游记》里的那个老头。他是个老头。
He's grumbling about the time. He's waving at a fly. I've had a real high protein shake with spiruline and everything in it. I should be vibrating right now. But no, I'm supplementing it with ice green tea, and I'm still sluggish. But if I don't have anything going on, I'll feel sluggish about this time, and I will listen to my body and I'll lay down for sure. Wait a second, there's an if there?
他在抱怨时间。他在向苍蝇挥手。我喝了一杯高蛋白奶昔，里面加了螺旋藻和其他各种东西。我现在应该精神抖擞才对。但并没有，我喝冰绿茶来补充，但还是觉得无精打采的。不过如果我没什么事可做，在这个时间我就会觉得无精打采，我就会倾听我的身体，然后肯定会躺下来。等一下，这里有个“如果”？
How often do you have shit going on at three in the afternoon? But I mean, like, if I keep, if I'm busy enough, I'll keep, it'll keep me awake. You know what I mean? Like if I have a meeting or whatever, if I'm coming off of four consecutive zooms right into this thing. So I've been up, I've been at it. But it's still. Did you work out? I did work out.
你下午三点到底有多少事要忙？但我的意思是，如果我一直，如果我足够忙，它就会让我保持清醒。你知道我的意思吗？比如如果我有会议什么的，如果我连续开了四个Zoom会议直接转到这个节目。所以我一直在忙，一直在工作。但还是…… 你锻炼了吗？我锻炼了。
That's my problem. J.B., it's not the problem. It's the zooms. They suck the energy out. Staring at the screen for those meetings, I'm telling you, it's the worst. In-person meetings, we should all get back to the office, right, Will? Yeah, absolutely. You hear that America?
这就是我的问题所在，J.B.，问题不是这个。是Zoom会议。它们把能量都吸干了。为了那些会议盯着屏幕，我告诉你，这太糟糕了。线下会议，我们应该都回办公室去，对吧，威尔？对，绝对的。听到了吗，美国？
Well, you know what? You know what's funny? I will say, because I have been on the East Coast more this fall. in summer is because being in the city, I feel like just more energized in general. Yeah. Well, that's New York City. Never sleeps, never sleeps.
好吧，你知道吗？你知道什么好笑的吗？我得说，因为我今年秋天和夏天在东海岸呆得更多。因为在城里，我觉得总的来说更有活力了。对。好吧，那就是纽约市。永不眠，永不眠。
Yeah. Yeah. It's got a heartbeat. It really does have a heartbeat. Do you have a t-shirt that says I heart beat and why? It's a thong. That doubles into a t-shirt. Yeah, go ahead, Jason.
对。对。它有心跳。它真的有心跳。你有没有一件T恤上面写着“我爱心跳”，为什么？那是一条丁字裤。可以变成一件T恤。对，说吧，杰森。
Do you have something you want to? Today we got a big brain. Okay, he's not one of your fancy-dancy celebs that are going to clue you into the life of the rich and famous, okay? No, Sean Will, this today, we've got someone who's given you some of the best television available of the last 20 years. This is a writer, producer, director, and often all three on the projects that he gives us,
你有什么想……今天我们迎来了一个大人物。好吧，他可不是那种会向你透露富豪名流生活的花哨名人，对吧？不，肖恩，威尔，今天我们请来了一位在过去20年里为你带来过电视上最棒作品的人。这是一位编剧、制片人、导演，而且在他创作的项目中通常兼任这三个职位，
giving us the kind of specific and singular experience that we look for on television nowadays. He's got the nominations, the awards, he's got the education, the credentials. He's also got the looks, the taste, the kids, the wife. The wind at his back, and he's going to tell us how he keeps it all together while bringing us top entertainment with shows like Bones, Legion. and the massive hit Fargo and the new and spectacular alien earth. Folks, Noah Hawley.
为我们带来了我们在如今的电视上所寻找的那种独特而单一的体验。他有提名，有奖项，有学历，有资历。他还有外表，品味，有孩子，有妻子。顺风顺水，他将告诉我们，他是如何兼顾这一切，同时通过诸如《识骨寻踪》、《大群》以及大热剧《冰血暴》和全新壮观的《异形：地球》等节目为我们带来顶级娱乐的。各位，诺亚·霍利。
Oh, my God, wow. Take it easy, Sean. Don't attack him just yet. This is exciting for me. Good afternoon, Noah. Good afternoon. I'm not nervous and I'm going to speak very slowly. Good, yeah, good, good.
哦，天哪，哇。别急，肖恩。先别急着攻击他。这让我很兴奋。下午好，诺亚。下午好。我不紧张，而且我要说得很慢。很好，对，很好，很好。
Okay. Now, you're right in the middle of the country there. Aren't you in Texas? I am in Austin, Texas, yes. So you're two hours. I married to seventh generation Texan and I didn't read the fine print. So, she said we're going back to the motherland.
好的。现在，你正处于国家的中部。你不是在德克萨斯州吗？我在德克萨斯州奥斯汀，是的。所以你差两个小时。我娶了一个第七代德州人，而我没有看清细则。所以，她说我们要回到祖国。
Yeah, let's get them happy. I like it. It's my kind of place. You're not missing. Where did you come from? Well, I'm a New York City kid originally, and then there was a little San Francisco, there was some L.A., and yeah, now I'm here. You're not missing those places.
对，让他们高兴。我喜欢。这是我喜欢的地方。你没有错过。你从哪儿来的？嗯，我本来是个纽约市的小孩，然后呆过一小阵旧金山，呆过洛杉矶，对，然后现在我在这儿。你不怀念那些地方吗？
You're into Austin. I mean, I was in New York last week. It's, you know, you reach a certain point where you're rarely home anyway, so. Word. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, it's W-E-R-D, Sean. Yeah, yeah.
你喜欢奥斯汀。我是说，我上周在纽约。你知道，你到了某个阶段，反正你也很少在家，所以…… 真的。对。对，就是W-E-R-D，肖恩。对，对。
Welcome to the show, Noah. This is a long time coming. Thank you. We know each other a bit. Do you guys know him at all? How do you guys know each other? Just through mixers, you know, get-togethers. Yeah.
欢迎来到节目，诺亚。这一天我们等很久了。谢谢。我们稍微认识一下。你们认识他吗？你们是怎么认识的？就是通过聚会，你知道的，社交聚会。对。
Someone set us up once. Jason described you, and how did it if Jason's like, not one of your celebrity, like he was, that felt like a real shot across your bow, no, if I'm being honest. It's good, I mean. He's not one of these, like, these, you know, tabloid celebs, you know, that, you know, sometimes we're looking up. book on this show. That's you.
有人曾把我们凑到一起。杰森对你的描述是，如果杰森说，他不是那种你的名人，就像他那样，诺亚，说实话，这听起来像是在对你放暗枪。挺好的，我是说。他不是那种，这些，你知道的，八卦小报名人，你知道的，有时我们在本节目中……这本书里。那是你。
I've never been on a tabloid. Unless I've caught in the background of one of Jen shots, you know. I will say, you know, living in Austin, you know, I'll go to L.A. sometimes and I'll think, oh, right, I'm somebody. Sure. At the same time. The second you leave, you're nobody. Right.
我从来没上过八卦小报。除非我不小心出现在珍妮某张照片的背景里，你知道的。我得说，你知道，住在奥斯汀，你知道，我有时去洛杉矶会想，哦，对了，我还是个大人物。当然。与此同时。你一离开，你就什么都不是了。对。
Well, but no, sometimes there, I feel like it's the only place I've ever been where you can feel like nobody also, right? It has that status game that is very specific. But talk about that, though, like you are, for a lot of the people listening to this, and maybe only Tracy will be like, well, this Noah Hawley, you know, who is this fellow? For most people, they know exactly who you are and you're enormously well-known and very, very powerful in this industry. But is there a part of, let's put it this way, I've got a writer friend of mine
好吧，但是不，有时候在那里，我觉得这是我呆过的唯一一个能让你觉得自己什么也不是的地方，对吧？它有一种非常独特的地位游戏。不过聊聊这个吧，就像你一样，对于很多听这个节目的人来说，可能只有特雷西会觉得，嗯，这个诺亚·霍利，你知道，这家伙是谁？对大多数人来说，他们确切地知道你是谁，而且你在这个行业里名气极大，非常有权势。但是有没有一部分，换个方式说，我有个编剧朋友
who likes to also act. Is this you? No. He's an enormous writer, but couldn't give a shit about the writing, just wants to act. Oh, yeah. Do you see the kind of weight and power
他也喜欢演戏。这是你吗？不是。他是个大编剧，但根本不在乎写作，只想演戏。哦，对。你看到了那种分量和权力和你在写作中应该得到并配得上的东西吗？因为他没有。就像，他没有意识到，作为一名极其成功的作家，他已经在那里获得了金牌。这太难做到了。
in the writing that you should and deserve? Because he doesn't. Like, he doesn't get that, like, he's already got the gold medal there by being an incredibly successful writer. That's so hard to do. No, I'm very, look, I love all the parts of the job. I like to sit in a room and write a novel
不，我很，看，我喜欢这份工作的每一个部分。我喜欢坐在房间里写小说，
and the phone doesn't ring, and I like the writer's room element of it. I love to get on set and direct and the team support of it all. You know, I think what makes me happiest is the fact that I don't have to do just one of those things, that I can get my isolation and recharge, and then I can go out and be in public, you know,
而且电话铃不响，我也喜欢编剧室的氛围。我喜欢去片场导演以及团队对这一切的支持。你知道，我觉得最让我高兴的是，我不必只做其中一件事，我可以获得我的孤立感并充电，然后我可以出去面对公众，你知道，
and sort of command the ship and, you know, try to elevate everyone to do their best work. And you're creating these projects. You're creating these jobs. You're creating all these many, many, many people with employment. And, like, that's not something that often an actor or a star can do. I mean, they can generate heat for a project, but you're literally filling up blank pages
某种程度上掌控全局，并且，你知道，努力提升每个人，让他们发挥出最好的水平。你在创造这些项目。你在创造这些工作。你在为所有这些许许多多的人提供就业机会。而且，这通常不是演员或明星能做到的事情。我的意思是，他们可以为一个项目带来热度，但你是在字面意义上填满空白的页面，
and, like, creating a story and a world in a project and I just think it's just incredible so well thank you and he's Jason's not unlike our current president he's just enamored with men of power you know what I mean like he's and so he's just an awe of your power yeah you see the aura I appreciate that he can come over and tell my wife how powerful I am yeah now what about that right what about how old your kids 13 and 18 okay now so they're old enough to give it up that's exactly the same age as mine Do your kids give it up? Do they get what you do?
并且，就像，创造一个故事、一个世界和一个项目，我只觉得这太不可思议了，所以谢谢你。而且杰森和我们现任总统没什么两样，他就是迷恋有权有势的男人，你知道我的意思吗？就像他那样，所以他只是对你的权力感到敬畏。对，你看那个光环。我很感激他可以过来告诉我的妻子我有多强大。对，那么那个呢？对，你的孩子多大了？13岁和18岁。好吧，现在他们大到可以放弃了。这跟我的一模一样。你的孩子会放弃吗？他们懂你在做什么吗？
Do they like what you do? Yeah, I think so. You know, I don't know how it is with you, but probably one more than the other. You know, I think, you know, my son loves to, he's the 13-year-old. He loves to come to set, give me a headset, I'm going to sit on the camera rig, you know.
他们喜欢你做的事吗？对，我想是的。你知道，我不知道你们的情况怎么样，但可能一个比另一个更感兴趣。你知道，我猜，你知道，我儿子喜欢，他是那个13岁的孩子。他喜欢来片场，给我一个耳机，我要坐在摄像机支架上，你知道。
Oh, that's cool. He's, you know, I call him the mayor of childhood, you know, and then my daughter's a little more retiring, a little, you know, less, I don't know. I mean, she appreciates it in a different way, I think, you know. And I think he's like, you know, where's my director's chair? Right, right, right.
哦，那太酷了。他，你知道，我叫他童年市长，你知道，然后我女儿稍微内向一点，稍微，你知道，少一点，我不知道。我是说，她以一种不同的方式欣赏它，我想，你知道。然后我觉得他在想，你知道，我的导演椅在哪里？对，对，对。
Is she either one of them interested in the industry? Early, too early to tell, I feel like, yeah. I mean, my son did ask me on Alien Earth. He's like, is there any role? Like, could I do anything in there? And so I did put him in the show just in a sort of improv. He plays the young Alex Lothar character. and you know I wasn't going to write a scene
他们俩有人对这个行业感兴趣吗？还早，现在说还太早，我觉得，是的。我是说，我儿子在《异形：地球》时确实问过我。他说，有什么角色吗？比如我能在里面做点什么吗？所以我确实把他安排进去了，在一个即兴表演中。他扮演年轻的亚历克斯·洛瑟角色，
but I wanted that kind of feeling of that the kind of Maliki feeling of the childhood thing and I was like I can't hire a day player to be his dad and then I got he's never acted before and so you know I'm always the guy who's like maximum creativity maximum efficiency I was like the easiest thing to do is if I just get down on the floor and I play the dad and I'm there with him
而且你知道我本来不打算写一场戏的，但我想要那种感觉，那种童年的马拉基式的感觉，我就想，我不能雇一个日薪演员来演他爸爸，然后我，他从来没演过戏，所以，你知道，我总是那种追求最大创造力、最高效率的人，我就想，最简单的事就是我自己趴到地板上，我来演爸爸，我和他在一起。
and you did that I did it was a really kind of special day certainly and and it did i loosened him up we you know we had a good time and and it's great were you at the end of i've seen every episode we're at the end of that day where you're like hey hey the dad character might need a spin-off exactly because you know this guy's really got something exactly but can you tell me like because i i'm a massive massive fan and my husband scotty of the alien series of we've seen every movie everything in between and all incarnations and and then when we saw this show coming up Alien Earth, we're like, wait, finally somebody's like doing a series of it. And how did that come to you? And did you feel the weight of it because we're like,
你真的这么做了。我做了，那真的是一个很特别的日子，当然，而且它确实，我让他放松了下来，我们，你知道，我们度过了一段美好的时光，而且这很棒。你在那天的尾声时——我看过每一集——你有没有想过，“嘿，嘿，爸爸这个角色可能需要一个衍生剧”？完全是这样，因为你知道这家伙真的很有料，完全是这样。但是你能告诉我吗，因为我是一个超级超级大粉丝，我的丈夫斯科特也是《异形》系列的粉丝，我们看过每一部电影、中间的所有作品以及所有衍生版本，然后当我们看到这部即将上映的剧集《异形：地球》时，我们就想，哇，终于有人在拍它的剧集了。你是怎么接触到这个项目的？你有没有感受到它的分量，因为我们当时在研究……
we did the nerd stuff. We're like, let's find out where it falls into the storyline, you know, and the history. And it's really cool. I love it so much. It starts before the original alien, correct? Yes, it's a couple of years before. And after the Prometheus and the covenant, right? In between? Yeah, I think I think that's accurate. You know, I felt like I wanted... I mean, Sean, if you don't mess up your microphone here, okay? Put some plastic over it. One of us is an expert on alien, but I don't think it's me.
我们做了那些书呆子的事。我们在想，弄清楚它在故事情节和历史中处于什么位置，你知道。这真的很酷。我太喜欢它了。它开始于第一部《异形》之前，对吧？是的，早几年。而且在《普罗米修斯》和《契约》之后，对吧？在中间？对，我想，我想这是准确的。你知道，我觉得我想……我是说，肖恩，如果你不在这里弄乱你的麦克风的话，好吧？在上面盖块塑料。我们中有一个是异形专家，但我觉得那不是我。
Okay, okay, yeah. Because, Sean, according to your timeline, actually... It's the glasses. I got the new glasses, so they make me alien smart. No, but yeah, did you feel the weight of it, and how did it come to you, and how did you create it? Yeah, I mean, it's, you know, I've now... had this opportunity a couple of times, right, to take a classic film and turn it into a TV show. And, you know, for me, it's never about going back and rewatching the film, right?
好吧，好吧，对。因为，肖恩，根据你的时间线，其实…… 是眼镜。我换了新眼镜，所以它们让我变得像异形一样聪明。不，但是，是的，你感受到它的分量了吗？你是怎么接触到它的，又是怎么创作它的？是的，我是说，你知道，我经历过……现在有几次这样的机会了，对吧，把一部经典电影改编成电视剧。而且，你知道，对我来说，这绝不是关于回去重看这部电影，对吧？
It's about thinking about, well, how does that film live in my imagination, and what are the feelings that it brings up in me? And how can I create those same feelings in an audience by telling them a different story, you know? The thing with an alien movie is it's a two-hour survival story, but a TV show has to be the opposite, right? You have to invest in 10 or 30 or 50 hours about characters who don't die, right? And so, well, what is it if it's not a two-hour survival story? And so there needs to be, you know,
这是关于思考，那部电影是如何活在我的想象中的，它在我心中唤起了什么感觉？我如何通过给观众讲一个不同的故事，在他们身上创造出那种相同的感觉，你知道的？异形电影的问题在于它是一个两小时的生存故事，但电视剧必须恰好相反，对吧？你必须投入10小时、30小时或50小时去关注那些不会死的角色，对吧？所以，好吧，如果它不是一个两小时的生存故事，那它会是什么呢？所以这就需要，你知道……
even if you have 60% of the best action in horror, you still have 40% of what are we talking about, right? What's the show about and everything? So that's where it, It started for me, and it came down to this one moment in Ridley's movie where, you know, the monster's out, and Sigourney's in the communication room, and the computer is telling her that the crew is expendable, and she leans back, and Ian Holm is there, and you realize he's an android. And I thought, well, that moment in which humanity realizes it's trapped between nature and technology,
就算恐怖片里最精彩的部分你占了60%，可剩下的40%讲的是什么呢？对吧？这剧到底是讲什么的？所以这就是我的起点，它源于雷德利电影里的一个瞬间：你知道的，怪物出来了，西格妮在通信室里，电脑告诉她船员是可牺牲的，她往后一靠，伊恩·霍姆就在那里，然后你意识到他是个生化人。当时我想，人类意识到自己被夹在大自然和科技之间的那个瞬间，
and they're both trying to kill us, that feels like the moment we're living in. Right, totally. And that feels like what the show is about. Yeah, for sure. I got that. I got all that. Sky locked the doors. Yeah.
而它们俩都想弄死我们，那种感觉就像我们现在正身处的时代。没错，完全是。这感觉就是这部剧的主题。没错，肯定的。我懂了。我都懂了。天网锁上了门。没错。
But also this, also that one creature that you created in the show was just the one eye, you know, like, and that inserts itself into other animals and humans. Yeah. It's just the one eye. Like, it's so creepy and clever and it's like, and holds like all the mystery. Like, I think it's so cool. Yeah, well, like I said, what are the feelings? that the original gave me. Well, the one feeling that the movie,
但还有这个，剧里你创造的那个生物，就只有一只眼睛，你知道的，就那种，它会钻进其他动物和人类体内。对。就只有一只眼睛。这太诡异、太巧妙了，而且它身上凝聚了所有的神秘感。我觉得酷毙了。对，正如我刚才所说，原版电影带给我的是什么感觉？好吧，电影带给人的一种感觉，
your first movie has, right, is the discovery of the life cycle of the creature. Wait, it's an egg, and then the thing comes out and attaches to your face, I'm out, right? But then, no, it gets worse. Then you falls off and you think, oh, I'm hungry, and you have a meal,
你的第一部电影里有的，对吧，就是探索这种生物的生命周期。等等，它是个卵，然后有东西钻出来贴到你脸上，我可受不了，对吧？但还没完，更糟的还在后面。然后它脱落了，你以为，哦，我饿了，你吃了一顿饭，
and the next thing is first out. And then it grows to be 10 feet tall, but that's the one feeling we can never get back for an audience, right? is that discovery, unless we introduce these new creatures, right? Right, right, right. So we go, all right, well, it's an eyeball with tentacles
紧接着它就破胸而出了。然后它能长到10英尺高，但这是我们对观众再也无法重现的一种感觉，对吧？就是那种探索感，除非我们引入这些新生物，对吧？对，对，对。所以我们就在想，好吧，它是一个带着触手的眼球，
and how does it reproduce and what does it eat? And I don't like that, you know. Wait, wait, wait, wait. So how do you, this is a great point. This is about my mom. This is one eye. No, Sean, I'm not going to reach for the low-hanging fruit, even though it's still fruit.
它是怎么繁殖的？它吃什么？我不喜欢那样，你知道的。等等，等等，等等，等等。所以你是怎么，这真是个好点子。这让我想到了我妈。这就是那只单眼。不，肖恩，我才不会去摘那些触手可及的果子，哪怕它确实是个果子。
That's the thing about low-hanging fruit. No, is that when you come up with a, When you come up with a creature like that, like what are the things that it's got the tentacles and stuff? What is that process? Are you guys in the writer's room going like, are you people pitching? Like, no, no, no, no, he's got eight tentacles. Yeah.
这就是触手可及的果子的特点。不，意思是当你构思一个，当你构思出这样一个生物时，比如它有哪些特征，长着触手什么的？那个过程是怎样的？你们在编剧室里会这样吗，大家都在提意见？比如，“不，不，不，它有八条触手。”对。
Because one of them, no, no, no, hang on a second. And like, how do you write that? No, it's really interesting. You know, the writer's room, you know, I have a kind of love-hate relationship with the writer's room. I had to figure out how to use it for myself. And what I figured out about it is it's a really, good way for to help me think out loud you know so I don't tend to let the room
因为其中一条，不，不，不，等一下。这种东西该怎么写？不，这真的很有趣。你知道的，编剧室，你知道我对编剧室有一种又爱又恨的复杂感情。我必须摸索出如何为我所用。我对它的理解是，这是一个非常好的地方，
dictate tell the story I tend to go in there and I go here here's where we are and then if I can't be in the room tomorrow I'll say all right well you know it's like let's say assimilation is a big theme in this story why don't you talk tomorrow about how that theme plays into all the characters and then I'll come back and we'll talk about that and then we'll keep moving forward so sure but okay so then So then let's say you have an idea for a specific creature. Yeah. What are you, and are you talking with the folks with, like, some of the design folks
能帮我大声思考，你知道的，所以我通常不会让编剧室来主导、决定故事走向。我通常会走进房间说：行了，我们现在进展到这儿了。然后如果明天我没法去房间，我就会说：好吧，比如说，同化是这个故事的一个核心主题，你们明天讨论一下这个主题是如何体现在所有角色身上的，然后我回来咱们再聊，接着我们继续推进。所以，当然了，但是——好吧，那么——那么假设你对某个特定生物有了个想法。对。你是在构思的时候，和那些设计人员
and the people about that as you're coming up with it? And are they talking to you about limitations? Or they're like, well, we don't know if we can have it, you know, suck its own eyeball out. Eyeball out. Family programming. Yeah. Jason was immediately like, can they do that? What planet do I need?
以及其他人探讨这些的吗？他们会跟你讨论局限性吗？还是会说，嗯，我们不知道能不能让它，你知道的，把自己的眼球吸出来。吸出来。家庭合家欢节目。对。杰森马上就问：它们能做到那个吗？我需要去哪个星球？
but you know what I mean like what is that process of figuring yeah I mean first it's a script process that you know that was my process it's sort of function over form right it's it's you know what am I looking for out of this thing and and and you know both in it's how it presents to start and then you know well okay here's this other creature and and you know it's a horrible thing that sucks your blood and then you realize that it lays its eggs in your drinking water. Well, that's worse, right? And then, you know, and so then we go into a design process,
但你知道我的意思吗，弄清楚这个过程是怎样的？对，我的意思是，首先这是一个剧本创作过程，你知道的，这就是我的过程，有点像是功能优先于形式，对吧？就是，你知道的，我从这东西身上想要得到什么？而且，你知道的，不管是它最初如何登场，然后你知道——好吧，这里还有另一个生物，
which was with the folks at Weta. And yeah, we kind of worked through it and... And how long from concept and writing to the time I saw the first episode? How many years? Oh, I mean, that was four years, five years. Wow. Yeah, I mean, there was, we all remember being on strike, right?
你知道的，这是一个会吸你血的可怕东西，然后你发现它把卵产在你的饮用水里。好吧，这更糟，对吧？然后，你知道的，所以接下来我们就进入了设计阶段，
That was in the middle. And so that was tough. But it was like a full year of post-production, which... By the way, and even after five years, still relip... Like, the second you watch the first episode, you're like, oh, this is exactly what's happening in the world today. There was no chat GPT when I started. Yeah, so that's how the zeitgeist rose up to meet me.
那是和维塔工作室的人合作的。对，我们一起把这个搞定了……从概念和写作到我看到第一集，中间隔了多久？多少年？哦，我的意思是，那是四年、五年。哇。对，我的意思是，大家还记得我们经历过罢工吧，对吧？
Yeah, it's wild. Really cool. Did you... When you were a young writer just starting out, and forgive me, I don't know your origin story, to put it in Sean's terms, do you... Were you, did you always have a bent for Reddit? Because you've done a lot of different stuff. You've written all kinds of genres, you know, in your professional career.
那正好赶在中间。所以那段日子挺艰难的。不过后期制作花整整一年时间，这……顺便说一句，甚至在五年之后，重看时依然……就像你观看第一集的那一秒，你会觉得，哦，这不就是当今世界上正在发生的事情吗？我刚开始写的时候可没有什么ChatGPT。对，所以这就是时代精神崛起并与我不期而遇的过程。
And novels, too. And novels. So did you see yourself... You write novels? Did you see yourself... Six of them? I do. Writing this kind of stuff when you were young?
哇，太疯狂了。真的很酷。你……当你还是个刚出道的年轻编剧时——恕我直言，我不了解你的背景故事，用肖恩的话说——你……你以前一直对Reddit这种东西很有偏爱吗？因为你做过很多不同的事情。在你的职业生涯中，你写过各种各样的类型。
Did you have a hankering for this? Did you have... Was this a genre that you were into? I'm speaking specifically about the alien world. Yeah, I mean, I'm a third... Like pre-Pometheus. Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
还有小说。还有小说。所以你觉得自己……你写小说吗？你觉得自己……六本小说？我是。年轻时就会写这种东西吗？
I'm a third generation writer. Both my mother and her mother were writers. And my grandma had an eighth grade education off the boat from Ukraine, and my mother had a high school education. And so I knew early on that writing is just something you call yourself, and then you have to earn it. There's no special degree or anything. And I think that's liberating because you're not learning how to write
你对这个感兴趣吗？你有过……这是你喜欢的题材吗？我特指异形的世界。对，我的意思是，我是第三代——就像《普罗米修斯》之前。对。对，对，对。
from people who are judging your work. You know, you got to assume that you're going to write some bad things and then the next thing might be better and then the thing after that may be better. And, you know, I was, you know, I mean, the first writing I did was songwriting as a musician. Oh, wow. You know, I played guitar and had a band
我是第三代作家。我母亲和她母亲都是作家。我外祖母只有八年级学历，是从乌克兰坐船来的，我母亲则是高中学历。所以我很早就明白，作家只是一个自封的称呼，然后你必须靠实力去赢得它。没有什么特殊的学位之类的。我觉得这很解放，因为你不是在向那些对你的作品评头论足的人学习写作。
and then realized I'm not a night person, right? So that was not a line of work that was going to work out, really for me. Jason's not an afternoon person. Yeah. What was that first thing? the little hit you got on the hook that like said okay i'm i'm good i i know i think i know how to write because yeah well you did you didn't you got it you got a degree in political science right it wasn't in in in in writing was it or did you minor in there geez man no yeah i was just
你知道，你得做好心理准备：你会写出一些糟糕的东西，然后下一部可能会好一点，再接下来的那部可能会更好。而且，你知道的，我……我的意思是，我最早的写作其实是作为音乐人写歌词。哦，哇。你知道的，我弹吉他，组过乐队，
you know studying things that were interesting to me and then and then you know writing on on the side um you know it's interesting there was in high school you know there was an assignment we were reading the book catch 22 right and and very specific voice in that book comedic satirical and there was an assignment which is write your own chapter of catch 22 right and i remember that being the first thing and kind of interesting considering i ended up you know write a cohen brothers movie and write a ridley scott movie that there was something to that exercise of of joseph heller's voice of finding it going oh i know what that is and i know how to do it that that that ended ended up being really seminal for me, I guess.
然后发现我不是个夜猫子，对吧？所以那不是一条能走得通的职业道路，至少对我不合适。杰森可不是个下午型的人。对。最初是什么东西，给了你创作的灵感，让你觉得“好吧，我行，我大概知道该怎么写了”？因为，对，好吧，你，你拿的是政治学学位，对吧？不是写作专业的，对吧？或者你辅修过？天哪，伙计，不，对，我当时只是
Wow. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. I just have a quick question from Scotty, if that's okay. Oh, sure. Oh, we're not really taking calls right now. But it's good because that kind of happens. He says it feels like with your show
在研究自己感兴趣的东西，然后顺便写点东西。嗯，挺有意思的，在高中时，你知道的，有个作业是让我们读《第22条军规》这本书，对吧？那本书里有一种非常独特的语调——喜剧式的、讽刺式的。当时有个作业是：写一段属于你自己的《第22条军规》章节，对吧？我记得那是我的第一篇东西，而且挺有意思的，考虑到我后来居然去写了一部科恩兄弟的电影，还写了一部雷德利·斯科特的电影——约瑟夫·海勒的那种声音，那种练习对我有某种特殊的意义，去找到那种感觉并说“哦，我知道那是什么，我也知道该怎么做”——最终这对我产生了深远的影响，我想是的。
with the upcoming release of the movie Predator Badlands, which features a character from the alien universe, that both the alien franchise and the Predator franchise are finally being codified in the same universe. Do you see the world of Predator being folded into the world you created an alien? No, I've wrecked my microphone. Do you see them combined at all?
哇。我们马上回来。现在，欢迎回到节目中。如果可以的话，我这里有斯科蒂的一个简短问题。哦，当然。哦，我们现在其实不接听电话。不过挺好的，因为这种事时有发生。他说感觉在你的剧里，
Or Predator coming onto your show? No, not onto the show, I don't think. I mean, I think Dan Tractenberg, who made Prey and has made The Badlands movie. And, you know, I mean, I loved Prey. I think he's doing a great job with that franchise. He clearly has a plan there. You know, I've met Dan once.
随着即将上映的电影《铁血战士：荒地》（Predator: Badlands）中出现了一个来自异形宇宙的角色，异形系列和铁血战士系列终于被编排到同一个宇宙中了。你觉得铁血战士的世界会被纳入你创作的异形世界吗？不，我把麦克风弄坏了。你觉得它们会被结合在一起吗？
We're not kind of coordinating any of that stuff. Yeah, yeah, okay, fine. It's not really my plan to do it. Sure. So just tell Scottie to stand down. Yeah. He just comes in in a predator outfit. I'm like, okay.
或者铁血战士会客串到你的剧里？不，不会客串到剧里，我觉得不会。我的意思是，我觉得执导了《狩猎生死》（Prey）并拍了《荒地》的丹·特拉亨伯格……而且，你知道的，我很喜欢《狩猎生死》。我觉得他在那个系列上做得很好。他在那里显然有全盘计划。你知道的，我和丹见过一次面。
Yeah. Well, so, no, tell us about that moment that the switch from political science to writing. Was there a first job? Was it a school paper? Like, what was that transition? No, I mean, I had done some fiction writing
我们并没有在协调这些事情。对，对，好吧，没关系。这其实不是我的计划。行吧。所以就告诉斯科蒂稍安勿躁。对。他要是真穿着铁血战士的衣服闯进来，我只会觉得：好吧。
and, you know, as a kid. And then in college, and as I said, I was trying to be a rock star. But, you know, to make ends meet, I took a job working as a paralegal for the Legal Aid Society in New York City in family courts.
好吧，那么，跟我们聊聊从政治学转向写作的那个转折点吧。有第一份工作吗？是校报吗？那次转变是怎么发生的？不，我的意思是，我以前写过一些小说，
So these are the lawyers who represent children in abuse and neglect cases to termination of parental right cases but also juvenile delinquency cases so both civil and criminal law. And what did you do, sorry? What did you do?
你知道的，还是个孩子的时候。然后到了大学，正如我所说，我当时正努力想成为摇滚巨星。但是，为了维持生计，我在纽约市法律援助协会的家庭法庭找了一份律所助理（paralegal）的工作。
I was a paralegal. I basically tried to help them you know, case law, et cetera. And, you know, it was... If a dad took off in a, you know, in a car... In a meada. Let's say we're talking.
所以这些律师代表的都是儿童，处理的案件从虐待和忽视儿童案、剥夺父母抚养权案，到少年违法犯罪案，既有民事也有刑事。你当时做什么，不好意思？你都做些什么？
Let's say there was a lot of wheel spin. It was an M.G. And there was just four or five kids in the rear view. Would you, you would take that case on, yes, even if it was in Chicago? Those kids deserve their day in court, is all right. All right, all right, I'm going to tell my dad I'll see you in court, yeah. Yeah, but, you know, and the family court, the family court building at that time was this huge black obelisk. It looked like Darth Vader's helmet.
我是一名律所助理。我基本上是尝试帮他们查找判例法等等。而且，你知道的……如果有个爸爸开车跑了……开着马自达。咱们打个比方。
Yeah. And so every day I'd go to work and these kids would come in and, you know, it's obviously, it's, it's, it's, It's heartbreaking, you know, it's outrageous, et cetera. And I started writing fiction as a way to kind of process. Yeah, escape a little. And, you know, when you're in a band, you're tied to these three filthy, penniless men, right? And fiction writing was a way to, I could just do it myself. And, you know, when you wrote 10 pages, you had 10 pages, right?
假设当时有很多轮胎打滑的场景。那是一辆名爵（M.G.）。后视镜里塞了四五个孩子。你会接手那个案子吗？是的，哪怕它在芝加哥？那些孩子理应在法庭上得到公正，就这样。行，行，行，我要跟我爸说我要法庭上见你，对。对，但是，你知道的，当时的家庭法庭大楼是一座巨大的黑色方尖碑。它看起来就像达斯·维达的头盔。
Was your material dark at that time? Was it a reflection of what you were going through? Well, no, I've always. been playful and you know I've always been attracted to genre and elevating genre you know as character pieces etc so I don't know you know the first novel I published was called a conspiracy of tall men and it was about a professor of conspiracy theories whose wife has killed in a plane crash and he finally gets the conspiracy he's been looking for but of course it's no solace because you know he had to lose his wife to get it and it has a bit of a thriller quality it's also
所以每天我去上班时，这些孩子走进来，你知道的，这显然……这让人心碎，令人发指，等等。我开始写小说，以此作为一种排解的方式。对，稍微逃避一下。而且，你知道的，当你加入乐队时，你得和另外三个又脏又穷的男人绑在一起，对吧？而写小说是一种我能独自完成的方式。你知道的，当你写了10页，你就拥有了10页，对吧？
a little satirical. You know, I'm always just trying to figure out how does the story want to be told? Wait, but the time is a paralegal and witnessing all of that, you know, horrible stuff to kids and the parents and the families. How did that affect you? And how do you see the, how did that change who you are
你那时的素材很黑暗吗？那是你当时经历的写照吗？嗯，不，我一直都是
as a person, as a writer, as a parent after being experienced and after experiencing all of that? Yeah, well, believe me, I tell my kids every day, you got it good, you don't know how good you got it. Right, for sure. No, it's interesting, you know, because my daughter is 18, as I said, and if I look back at the last 20 years of stories that I've told really,
比较爱玩的，而且你知道，我一直对类型片以及提升类型片（比如作为性格片等）很感兴趣，所以我不知道，你知道的，我出版的第一本小说叫《高个子男人的阴谋》（A Conspiracy of Tall Men），讲的是一个阴谋论教授，他的妻子在空难中丧生，他最终得到了他一直苦苦追寻的阴谋，但当然，这毫无慰藉，因为你知道，他必须失去妻子才能得到它。它有点惊悚片的质感，同时也
you know, I can't separate my identity as a parent from the stories I'm telling. You know, I look at Alien Earth, which is about these children whose minds are put into adult bodies or Fargo Season 4, which is about these two crime bosses who trade their youngest sons. There's always something that ties into, like, who are we as a people, how are we raising our children and what is moral and what is cynical and how are we preparing our kids for the world? Right, right, right.
带有一点讽刺色彩。你知道的，我总是只是在琢磨：这个故事想要以什么方式被讲述出来？等等，但你当律所助理的那段经历，目睹了所有那些对孩子们、父母们以及家庭来说极其糟糕的事情，那对你有什么影响？在经历了这一切之后，你觉得那如何改变了身为
I mean, Noah, how do you, do you have a structured way in which you divvy up your day to tackle these, to allow your brain to think, what do I want to do, what do I want to say, what should this episode be about, what should my next project be about? And then do you have a certain time, like is in the afternoon where you actually then do the writing
个人、身为作家、身为父母的你？对，好吧，相信我，我每天都对我的孩子们说：你们现在过得太好了，你们根本不知道自己有多幸福。真的，确实。不，这挺有意思的，你知道的，因为正如我所说，我女儿今年18岁了，如果我回看过去20年里我讲过Những故事，
and then another period of time the time management of it and like how do you I just can't imagine how you take on as much concentrated individual time along with all the time you need to spend with the teams that you're running it kind of depends on what phase I'm in right you know right now
你知道的，我无法将我作为父母的身份与我所讲述的故事分离开来。你看《异形：地球》，讲的是这些孩子的心智被放入成年人的身体里；或者《冰血暴》第四季，讲的是两个黑帮老大互换了他们的小儿子。总有一些东西与以下这些息息相关：我们作为人类究竟是谁，我们是如何抚养孩子的，什么是道德，什么是愤世嫉俗，我们是如何为我们的孩子步入世界做准备的？对，对，对。
you know I can look at at having to have scripts do in a few months and production coming up. And, you know, I'm sort of in a phase right now, which is every day I'm like, where does my brain want to go? You know? And so, and some days that that's like, you know, I want to watch movies or, you know, I want to read this book.
我是说，诺亚，你是否有某种结构化的方式来分配你的一天，以应对这些事情，让你的大脑去思考：我想做什么，我想表达什么，这一集该讲什么，我的下一个项目应该是什么？然后你是否有特定的时间，比如在下午你真正开始写作，
And other days it's like, oh, I guess I'm going to think about, you know, Alien Earth today or I'm going to think about Fargo today. And, you know, in that way, you know, when an idea is new, you don't want to look at it directly. you want to side-eye it you know you're like it's fragile you're like i don't know what this is yet and i don't want to scare it so and i don't want to tell anybody about it and i just kind of kind of and then after after a few days or a couple of weeks you sort of go okay now i see a little more clearly you know i think i can start to make some hard hard choices here it starts chasing you
然后又是另一个时间段来管理时间，你是怎么——我简直无法想象，你如何在处理好你所带领的团队所需的大量集中时间的同时，又兼顾这么多集中的个人时间？这在很大程度上取决于我处于哪个阶段，对吧？你知道的，现在
yeah i like that idea i like to keep things out into kind of a soft focus i always say like just keep it out there in a soft focus for now yeah let it kind of let it come into let it sort of marinate and come into focus on its own a little bit. You know, Jason was saying you've got all these different things that you're working on. And when they're in production, I imagine they're in production in lots of different locations as well, which must also be a big issue.
你知道的，我得考虑到几个月后就要交剧本，而且制作马上就要开始了。而且，你知道的，我目前正处于这样一个阶段，每天都在想：我的大脑想去哪里？你知道的？所以，有些时候那意味着——你知道的——我想看电影，或者——你知道的——我想读这本书。
Yeah, you know, we love Canada. We film a lot in Canada. But no, I mean, I shot Alien Earth in Bangkok. We were in Thailand for, you know, what was probably a total of a year. You know, I wasn't there the whole time. I'm there for a couple of months a couple of months there. But, yeah, it's hard. It's hard.
而另一些时候则是：哦，我想我今天要开始思考《异形：地球》了，或者我今天要思考《冰血暴》了。而且，通过这种方式，你知道的，当一个新想法诞生时，你不能直接盯着它看，
And if I can time it to a kid's summer vacation, it's easier. And if not, we try to have a two-week rule. But can't come back from Thailand for a weekend, you know what I mean? I was just going to ask to mimic your son and say, look, if there's a part in alien earth from me. I always say you can't come back from a weekend in Thailand. You know what I mean? Well, it's metaphorical and literal. Yeah.
你得斜着眼看它，你知道的，你会觉得它很脆弱，你会觉得：我还不知道这是个啥，我不想吓跑它，我也不想把这事告诉任何人，我只想……然后过几天或者几周后，你才会觉得：好吧，现在我看得更清楚一点了，你知道的，我想我可以在这里做出一些艰难的抉择了。它开始追着你跑了。
Jason, anything? No, there, it is a coincidence, no, but incredible that you have adapted, as you said earlier, two iconic films into television series. Is that a coincidence or, well, let's start with Fargo. How did you have the moxie to say, I want to approach the Coen brothers and talk to them about turning their iconic film into a television series? and then how did you do that again with Ridley Scott? Yeah, I mean, luckily these were both
对，我喜欢这个主意，我喜欢把事情保持在一个虚焦的状态。我总是说：先让它处于虚焦状态吧。对，让它慢慢酝酿，然后自己聚焦清晰一点。你知道的，杰森刚才说你手头上有这么多不同的事情在忙。当它们进入制作阶段时，我想象它们也会在很多不同的地点进行制作，这一定也是个大问题。
sort of incoming calls. I had written a couple of pilots for FX. I knew them. I was in talking to them about something else. They had optioned Fargoat as a TV show. Joel and Ethan had signed on and they'd said if we like the script, you can put our name on it
各种电话。我当时为FX写过几个试播集，我了解他们。我和他们在谈别的事情。他们买下了《冰血暴》电视剧的改编权。乔尔和伊桑签了字，他们说如果我们喜欢剧本，你们就可以挂上我们的名字
and if not, you know where to send the check. And, you know, so the first process was to sell FX and to go through you know that process and write a script and then we sent that first script to Joel and Ethan and that was when I met them and and... Sorry, when FX optioned it
如果不喜欢，你知道支票该寄到哪。所以，你知道的，第一个流程是卖给FX，经历那个流程，写剧本，然后我们把第一版剧本寄给乔尔和伊桑，那就是我见到他们的时间。抱歉，在FX买下版权时
was it always going to be an anthology or was the original concede to take the original characters and keep moving them? Yeah, they wanted to make a TV show out of it but they also said do you think we could do it without Marge because how could you ever top Francis McDormand, right? And I said
它一开始就打算做成一部诗选剧吗，还是最初的构想是采用原版角色并让他们继续发展？对，他们想把它拍成电视剧，但也说：“你觉得我们没有玛姬还能拍吗？因为你怎么可能超越弗兰西斯·麦克多蒙德呢，对吧？”我说
well first of all everyone else's dead are in jail. So, all right, well, that's interesting. If you're adapting the movie without actually any of the characters in the movie, then what are you doing? And I said, look, it's not a TV show because the movie says it's a true story. And at the end of it, she's seen the craziest Cohen Brothers case. And tomorrow's a normal day, and she's got two months left to have the baby,
首先，其他人不是死了就是坐牢了。所以，好吧，这很有意思。如果你在改编这部电影时实际上并不包含电影中的任何角色，那你在做什么？我说，听着，它不是一部电视剧，因为电影里说这是一个真实的故事。而在片尾，她见证了科恩兄弟最疯狂的案子。明天又是平常的一天，离她生孩子还有两个月，
and he got the three-cent stamp. And, you know what I mean? It's a closed-ended thing. If she woke up tomorrow and it was another crazy Cohen brother's case, you couldn't say it's a true story no one would would believe it right i said but you could you know why is the movie called fargo it's set in minnesota except that fargo the word is evocative of a place right what joel and ethan calls siberia with family restaurants and and you know but it's also after that movie it's kind of a state of mind it's a type of story and so i said you know so you could tell
而他拿到了那个三分钱的邮票。你懂我的意思吧？这是一个封闭的结局。如果她明天醒来又是一个疯狂的科恩兄弟案件，你就不能说这是一个真实的故事，没人会相信，对吧？我说，但是你可以……你知道电影为什么叫《冰血暴》吗？它故事设定在明尼苏达州，除了“法戈”这个词让人联想到一个地方，对吧？就像乔尔和伊桑所说的，到处都是家庭餐厅的西伯利亚，你知道的，但在这部电影之后，它也成了一种心境，一种类型的故事。所以我说，你可以讲述
this story about fargo and this is a fargo story or you know, as proved out, it could also be a 1979 crime epic about the death of the family business and the rise of corporate America, or it could be a 1950 story about, you know, the sort of alternate economy and immigration and et cetera. So every time I just try to push that envelope of what is a Fargo story. But it would all need to take place in Fargo, though, yes? No, it all needs to, I mean, not even really. Fargo, North Dakota, yes? Well, but it needs to have some connection, you know, whether there's a character, I mean, the fourth season took place in Kansas City,
这个关于法戈的故事，这是一个法戈的故事，或者正如后来证明的那样，它也可以是一部关于家族企业消亡和企业美国崛起的1979年犯罪史诗，或者它可以是一个关于另类经济、移民等等的1950年的故事。所以我每次都在努力打破界限，去探索什么是法戈的故事。但它们都需要发生在法戈，对吧？不，它们都需要，甚至不一定。北达科他州的法戈，对吗？嗯，但它需要有一些联系，无论是有一个角色——第四季发生在堪萨斯城，
but Jesse Buckley's character was from North Dakota, you know? And, you know, this last season with John Hamm, you know, he was in North Dakota. Oh, yeah. This fucking guy, I don't know how he gets fired. Honestly. Noah. Just, it's fucking unreal. It's a new goddamn ham vehicle.
但杰西·巴克利的角色的确来自北达科他州，你知道的？还有，最近这一季有乔恩·哈姆，他在北达科他州。哦，对。这该死的家伙，我真不知道他怎么会被炒。老实说。诺亚。简直太不真实了。又是一辆该死的哈姆大卡车。
Just let it out, man. Jesus. Jesus. We'll cut all of that. We'll cut all of that. And funny. All of that needs to be trimmed out, but I just needed to... Yeah, no, I'm glad you got that off your chest.
发泄出来吧，伙计。天哪。天哪。我们会把这些都剪掉的。我们会把这些都剪掉的。太搞笑了。所有这些都需要剪掉，但我只是需要……对，不，我很高兴你把这块心病说出来了。
So, sorry. Okay, so we're back. Yes. So the fourth season was with the Great John Hamm, right? Fifth season, fourth season? Yeah. Yep. That's your back in.
所以，抱歉。好吧，我们回来。对。所以第四季是和伟大的乔恩·哈姆合作的，对吧？第五季，第四季？对。没错。你绕回来了。
Fifth season was Chris Rock, and anyway. So, yeah, so they came to me. But then, of course, I realized, look, you know, it's great. I wrote a script that the Coen brothers, you know, when I spoke to them finally and they said it's you know we hate imitation but this was it was eerie reading this because it felt like you were channeling us right that's a great thing to hear that makes makes my millennia right but then but then you got to film it and and and there's we know we know that the coens they write or rewrite a lot of movies that they don't direct and those movies never feel
第五季是克里斯·洛克，总之。所以，他们找到了我。但随后，我当然意识到，听着，这很棒。我写了一个剧本，科恩兄弟——当我最终和他们交谈时，他们说，我们讨厌模仿，但读这个剧本时真有种毛骨悚然的感觉，因为感觉就像你在通过我们传递心声一样。听到这个太棒了，这让我的人生都圆满了，但是……但是你得把它拍成电影，而我们知道，科恩兄弟为很多他们不 directeur 的电影写过或重写过剧本，而那些电影从来没有
like cohen brothers movies so there's something in the cinema right that turns those words into that thing and I had to figure out what that was otherwise I was gonna fail on my face did you end up directing the first episode I didn't because I wasn't really directing then and so you know I had a director
科恩兄弟电影的感觉。所以电影里一定有什么东西，能把这些文字变成那种效果。我必须弄清楚那是什么，否则我会颜面扫地。你最后执导了第一集吗？我没有，因为我当时其实并不怎么执导，所以你知道的，我有一个导演——
yeah who was did somebody come in and say yeah here's the visual component that is the Cohen brothers yeah Adam Bernstein came in and he had shot a bunch of a breaking bad and we had a good collaboration but you know he he gave me his director's cut
有人走过来说，对，这就是科恩兄弟的视觉元素吗？亚当·伯恩斯坦来了，他拍过很多《绝命毒师》，我们合作得很愉快，但是，你知道，他给了我他的导演剪辑版。
And, you know, I recut it, you know. I recut it to find the tone of voice that, to me, felt like a Coen Brothers movie. It's not as comedic as you think, right? And a lot of the comedy is deployed, you know, like Anton Sugar's haircut. It's deployed in a way where you're like, well, it's not funny. It's just really specific and kind of unsettling. Right, right. But it ends up being funny, you know.
然后，你知道的，我重新剪辑了。我重新剪辑是为了找到那种在我看来属于科恩兄弟电影的语调。它其实没你想象的那么喜剧，对吧？而且很多喜剧效果的使用，就像安东·奇古尔的发型一样。它的使用方式会让你觉得，其实这并不搞笑。它只是非常具体，而且有点让人不安。对，对。但它最后确实变得很好笑，你知道的。
Yeah. Yeah. Well, one of the first things I did was I took like half the edits out of the episode, you know, because nothing makes something feel like television more than you're cutting every time someone talks, right? I mean, there's a scene in the emergency room where Martin Freeman meets Billy Bob for the first time, and I'm in this master shot sort of slowly pushing in. And, you know, Billy Bob gets up and moves over next to him, and that's the first cut, you know. That's a long time, right? But that's what a movie feels like.
对。我做的第一件事之一就是删掉了这一集里大约一半的剪辑，你知道的，因为没有什么比每次有人说话时都要切镜头更让人觉得这是电视剧了，对吧？急诊室里有一个场景，马丁·弗里曼在那里第一次见到比利·鲍勃，而我用了一个缓慢推拉的长镜头。然后，比利·鲍勃站起来，挪到他旁边，那是第一个切镜头，你知道的。那经历了很长时间，对吧？但这才是电影的感觉。
Sure. You trust the audience. So, wait, so who, like, because you're right. I love Martin Freeman. Sorry, I just had to say that. Have you seen his show, by the way? No, have you seen his show, the responder that he did? No, I haven't.
当然。你得信任观众。所以，等等，因为你说得对。我太喜欢马丁·弗里曼了。抱歉，我只是不得不说这个。顺便问一句，你看过他的剧吗？没有，你看过他的剧吗？他演的那个《响应》？没有，我没看。
The U.K.? Yeah. Oh, my God. He plays a cop in Liverpool. It's unbelievable. He's so good in that show. Please, I... I'll watch it.
英国的那个？对。噢，天哪。他在利物浦演一个警察。太不可思议了。他在那部剧里演得太好了。求你了，我……我会去看的。
Yeah, watch it. It's so, so... So the comedy that, like, it comes, like you were talking about, from the Coen brothers, who was that for you growing up? Who was the show, the movie, the people, the comedians that you're like, you know what, I really like that kind of style? Well, I grew up because my father had studied acting in the UK.
对，去看吧。太……所以，那种喜剧效果，就像你说的，来自科恩兄弟，在你成长过程中，谁对你有这种影响？有哪些剧、电影、人物、喜剧演员让你觉得，你知道吗，我真的很喜欢那种风格？嗯，我成长的时候，因为我父亲在英国学过表演。
He came back with a lot of Goon Show records, which was Spike Milligan and Peter Sellers and Harry Seekum, this radio, half-hour radio show. It was that, it was Monty Python, it was Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy. There was a lot of that British humor that really was seminal for me and then, you know, because people asked me, when was the first time you saw Alien
他带回了很多《军情五处》（Goon Show）的唱片，那是斯派克·米利根、彼得·塞勒斯和哈里·西科姆的半小时广播节目。除了那个，还有《巨蟒剧团》，还有《银河系漫游指南》。有很多那样的英式幽默对我的影响深远，然后，你知道的，因为有人问我，你第一次看《异形》是什么时候？
and I say, well, I'll tell you the first time I didn't see it was a nine-year-old's birthday party where my parents were like, yeah, you're not going to that. And so we went to see the in-laws instead, right, with Alan Arkin and Peter Fox. And I was like, I think that explains everything about me, right? You know, so, you know, that's the sort of thing, is the absurdism, but also, you know, the cinematic nature of it. Right, yeah.
我说，那我告诉你我没看的那次吧，是一个九岁生日派对，我父母说：“去你的，你可不能看那个。”所以我们去看《姻亲》代替了，对吧，有阿兰·阿尔金和彼得·法克斯。我想这解释了我的一切，对吧？你知道的，所以，这就是那种东西，荒诞主义，但同时也是它的电影感。对，没错。
Go ahead, Jason. Well, the first television writing gig came on Bones, yes? Yeah. Yeah. So you're a writer-producer on that, and then you start to create your own shows. So the unusuals in my generation were those two of the first, yeah. Both for ABC, yeah. And was it a difficult process to get the networks interested in your ideas?
请继续，杰森。好吧，你的第一份电视编剧工作是《识骨寻踪》，对吧？对。你是那里的编剧兼制片人，然后你开始创作自己的剧。《不法神探》在我那一代人里是其中前两部，对吧。都是为ABC拍的，对吧。让电视网对你的创意感兴趣是一个艰难的过程吗？
I mean, were they receptive right away based on your time there on bones? Was that kind of a tough transition into being a showrunner? No, I mean, I'd come from being a novelist to writing an original spec feature film that I ended up selling, and my first novel had been optioned, and they said, all right, well, now you're a screenwriter, so give it a shot. So I did some feature writing, and then, you know, the TV agents at the agency were like, would you ever think about doing TV? So I went out and I took some meetings.
我是说，根据你在《识骨寻踪》的经历，他们一开始就容易接受吗？从编剧过渡到剧集主管是一个艰难的转变吗？不，我是说，我从小说家转变成写原创电影剧本并成功卖出，我的第一部小说也被买下了版权，他们说：“好吧，现在你是个编剧了，试试吧。”所以我写了一些电影剧本，然后经纪公司的电视经纪人就问：“你有没有考虑过做电视？”所以我出去开了一些会。
I ended up selling a couple of TV pilots that I wrote. And I thought, well, if any of these ever get produced, I should know how to make a show. And so whatever it was, 2004, I came, I was in San Francisco. I came down to L.A. and I staffed on Bones. And I did it because Hart Hanson, who ran the show, said, well, you're going to learn how to make a show. Yeah. There were other shows where they're like, you're going to be in the room the whole time. And I was like, well, I know how to write, but I need to know how to produce a thing.
我最终卖出了几个自己写的电视剧试播集。我想，如果这些剧有朝一日能拍出来，我得知道怎么制作一部剧。所以不管那是哪一年，2004年，我来到旧金山。我来到洛杉矶，加入了《识骨寻踪》。我这么做是因为运作该剧的哈特·汉森说：“你会学会怎么制作一部剧的。”对。还有其他剧，他们会说：“你得一直待在编剧室里。”而我想的是：“我会写作，但我需要知道怎么制作一部作品。”
But then while I was on staff, you know, I was still, I published another book. I sold a movie script each season. I didn't write a pilot the first year, but the second year I went into ABC and developed a show with them that they really liked, but they didn't make, right? Because it didn't really have a genre, right? That was the broadcast days where they're like lawyer, Dr. Cop, right? So the next year I thought... Do you think that show would have been made today, sort of interrupt?
但在我加入剧组期间，我还在继续写作，我出版了另一本书。每个季度我都会卖出一个电影剧本。第一年我没写试播集，但第二年我去了ABC，和他们一起开发了一部他们非常喜欢但最终没拍的剧，对吧？因为这剧没有固定的类型，对吧？那是广播电视的黄金年代，他们只想要律师、医生、警察，对吧？所以第二年我想……你觉得那部剧如果放到今天能拍出来吗，不好意思打断一下？
I think so, yeah. It was a sort of white trash dynasty about a guy who had a used car empire and he had four families and everybody worked for him. And, you know, it was a really fun sort of... I want to watch that show. I see you as a lead on that, Willie.
我觉得可以。那是一个有点像白人群落动态的故事，讲的是一个拥有二手车帝国的家伙，他有四个家庭，每个人都为他工作。而且，那是一个非常有趣的故事……我想看那部剧。我觉得你很适合演主角，威利。
Yeah, for sure. And they really liked it in the character work. And so then strategically I thought, okay, well, I'm going to go back in the next year. What can I sell them that they would actually make? And I thought, well, let's sell them a cop show not a procedural but like a hill street or or a barney miller or something like that and so that's the show i pitched them and and then you know we we got it through the process with jeremy renner and
对，肯定的。他们真的很喜欢里面的角色塑造。所以出于战略考虑，我想，好吧，我明年还要再去。我能卖给他们什么他们真的会拍的东西呢？我想，好吧，卖给他们一部警匪剧，不是那种程序剧，而是像《希尔街的蓝调》、《巴尼·米勒》那样的剧。所以这就是我向他们推销的剧，然后我们通过杰瑞米·雷纳完成了整个流程。
and you know goldberg and harold perineau and and you know we did the eight hours and then they said thank you and and don't let the door hit you on the way out and then the next day jeremy renner was nominated for an oscar for hurt locker uh-huh right he's like you guys are real geniuses Yeah. Talk to us about how the directing thing started to come about and where did your confidence start to... When did your confidence start to grow for that? Like asking for the wheel?
还有戈德堡和哈罗德·佩里诺，我们完成了这八个小时的剧集，然后他们说谢谢，慢走不送。结果第二天，杰瑞米·雷纳就凭借《拆弹部队》获得了奥斯卡提名，哈哈，对吧？他就好像在说：“你们这群人真是天才。”哈哈。跟我们聊聊你是怎么开始接触导演的，你的自信是从哪里开始的……你的自信是什么时候开始增长的？比如开始主动要求掌控全局？
Yeah, I mean, you know, what you realize, especially when there's comedy in the work, right, is that where you see the joke is different than where somebody else sees the joke, right? With a beat. And even the Unusuals, pilot, right, is like Stephen Hopkins had directed it and, you know, he cut a much broader comedy than I saw, right? And so I would go in and, you know, so you start in the editing
是的，我是说，你意识到的是，特别是当作品中有喜剧元素时，你看到笑点的地方和别人看到笑点的地方是不一样的，对吧？通过一个节拍。甚至连《不法神探》的试播集也是，斯蒂芬·霍普金斯执导的，他剪辑出来的喜剧风格比我看到的要宽泛得多，对吧？所以我会介入，你知道的，你从剪辑
room to be a filmmaker. Right. You know, and where, you know, I'm not a, I'm not a big fan of melodrama. I like to keep the emotion sort of low until it's really earned. And, you know, and then my generation was a, it was a fake documentary. about the high school class of 2000 and where they were 10 years later and so I had to approach it like I was making a documentary film so you know
室开始成为一个电影人。对。你知道的，我不是……我不太喜欢情节剧。我喜欢把情绪压得比较低，直到它真正水到渠成。然后，你知道的，我那一代人拍的是一个伪纪录片。关于2000届的高中同学，他们10年后的生活，所以我必须像在拍纪录片一样去处理它。所以你知道的
when you watch a documentary you're like well the cameras weren't there they've got an audio recording or they've got still photographs or they've got you know or if the cameras were there and the couple had a fight and she ran off and he ran after her well the camera's not there waiting right the camera's chasing
当你观看一部纪录片时，你会想，摄像机当时不在那儿，他们有录音，或者他们有静态照片，或者你知道的，如果摄像机当时在那儿，情侣吵架了，她跑开，他追过去，摄像机可不是在那儿等着，对吧，摄像机是在追赶
right so so there was a cinematic mindset of making that. And then, of course, as I said, with the Coen Brothers film, you know, I started doing a lot of the second unit directing on the first season of Fargo,
对吧，所以这就有一种拍摄纪录片的电影思维。然后，当然，就像我说的，对于科恩兄弟的电影，我开始在《冰血暴》第一季中做了很多第二摄制组的导演工作，
and then I just started doing the episodic world creation in season two. Did you find it, I think most people can read something or watch something, and from the comfort of their couch, the safety of their couch, they can say, oh, I would do this differently
然后我从第二季开始就负责每集的独立世界构建了。你有没有发现，我想大多数人都能阅读或观看某样东西，在他们舒适的沙发上，在他们沙发的安全感中，他们会说：“哦，我会换个方式做这个，
or I would do that differently. And those are nine times out of ten, like really good ideas. They're good catches. They're good fixes. But if you give them a blank page or you give them a screen with no image on it or more pointedly on a set standing in front of a bunch of actors and some cameras and a cameraman, knowing how to create from the ground up to put this thing into three dimensions. Like did you find that change in the process from just from recutting stuff that's in front of you to actually creating it from the ground up on set,
或者我会换个方式做那个。”而且十有八九，那些都是很好的想法。它们是很好的捕捉点，很好的修正方案。但如果你给他们一张白纸，或者给他们一个没有任何画面的屏幕，或者更明确地说，在一个片场，站在一群演员、几台摄像机和一个摄影师面前，知道如何从头开始把这个东西变成三维的。就像你发现从重新剪辑你面前的东西，到在片场从头开始创作，这种过程中的转变，
was that a comfortable thing for you or would that have some growing pains? You know, I'm sure you had that moment the first time you're on a set and they go, what's next boss? And you don't know, right? That's scary. And 200 people are staring at you.
对你来说是一个适应的过程，还是有一些成长的阵痛？你知道的，我确信你在片场第一次听到有人问“接下来怎么走，老板？”时有过那种时刻。而你不知道，对吧？那太吓人了。有200个人盯着你。
You know, I've gotten comfortable with that feeling, which is like, I just need a minute, I'm going to figure it out. because then, of course, people start to offer suggestions, which isn't helpful, right, and everything. No, it was just about finding the, again, as I said, the feeling, and I don't have any training on this. And so a lot of it for me, you know, there's a moment on Alien Earth.
你知道的，我已经习惯了那种感觉，那就是：“我只需要一分钟，我会搞定的。”因为随之而来的是，大家开始提出建议，这其实并没有帮助，对吧，诸如此类。不，这只是关于寻找……再次强调，就像我说的，那种感觉，我在这方面没有任何科班训练。所以对我来说，很多时候，你知道，在《异形：地球》里有一个时刻。
I did that fifth hour, which was the trapped in the spaceship, you know, hour where, you know, you see what happened, before the ship crashed. And, you know, at this moment where Richard Morjani was running away from the xenomorph, and she was hiding, and she was pressed against a wall, and we could see down the hallway, and the xenomorph came out,
我拍了第五集，也就是被困在飞船里的那一集，你知道的，你在那里看到了飞船坠毁前发生了什么。然后，在这个时刻，理查德·莫贾尼正在逃离异形，她躲藏着，紧贴着墙壁，我们可以看到走廊那头，异形走了出来，
and I thought, well, I want to do a push in here, but let's do a zoom. And what if we zoom on her, and then we do it as a lockoff, and then I do a longer zoom on the xenomorph, and then I marry those two things. It's kind of an impossible shot. I don't know if it's going to work or not work,
我想，好吧，我在这里想要一个推镜头，但我们用变焦吧。如果我们把镜头拉近她，然后把它定格，接着对异形做一个更长时间的变焦，然后把这两者结合起来。这有点像一个不可能完成的镜头。我不知道它管不管用，
but I know it'll give you a feeling, right? Which is like, something feels wrong here, right? Which you don't know is a cinematic thing. You just feel that feeling, and that's sort of how I approach it. Super cool. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
但我知道它会给你一种感觉，对吧？也就是：这里有些地方不对劲，对吧？你不知道这是一个电影化的技巧。你只是能感受到那种感觉，这基本上就是我处理它的方式。太酷了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。
Did you find that once you got a kind of like J.B. You're saying, like, you could create from the ground up in real time as a director on set. Did you find that it took a step out of the process for you? Because as a writer, as a producer, as the showrunner, all these things, you're watching cuts or you're watching them shoot stuff. And you're like, yeah, and you're trying to convey what it is that you want. And at a certain point, just being able to cut the middleman out, as it were, was that satisfying? Well, look, my wife, Kyle, who I love dearly, she said, you know, at one point to me, do you have to direct two, right?
你有没有发现，一旦你——就像J.B.你说的——作为一个导演，你可以在片场实时从头开始创作？你有没有发现这为你省去了创作过程中的某个步骤？因为作为一个编剧、制片人、剧集主管，所有这些角色，你看着剪辑或者看着他们拍素材。然后你会说：“对，”然后你试图传达你想要的东西。在某种程度上，能够省去中间商，是不是挺满足的？听着，我的妻子凯尔，我深爱的妻子，她曾对我说过一句话：“你非得连导演也一起干吗？”
You know, and I said, but here's the thing. As opposed to just one? No, do you have to direct it all? Oh, you're writing, your show running, you also have to be a director. And I said, well, here's the thing. I'd have to be there anyway, right? The first episode of a new season, a new series, whatever, I got to be there anyway. It's actually, you're going to see me quicker if I do it myself.
你知道的，我说：“但问题是……”是相比于只做编剧吗？不，你非得什么都导演吗？噢，你既是编剧又是剧集主管，你还得当导演。我说：“好吧，问题是，反正我也得在那儿，对吧？”新一季、新剧的第一集，无论如何我都得在现场。实际上，如果我自己来拍，大家反而能更快见到成品。
Yeah, way more efficient. Yeah, so that's that, and for me, look, it's all an act of play, right? There's a, you know, as a writer, I'm a sort of yes-and improv guy, you know, in the room. I'm like, okay, I like that, we're doing that. Now what, right? I mean, I've heard these stories about Vince Gilligan where he's like, that's good. Let's spend two weeks seeing if we can top it. That would make me crazy.
对，效率高得多。对，就是这样，对我来说，这全是一种玩乐的行为，对吧？作为一个编剧，我在编剧室里是一个“对，然后”的即兴创作型的人，你知道的。我会说：“好吧，我喜欢这个，我们就这么办。接下来呢？”对吧？我的意思是，我听过关于文斯·吉里根的那些故事，他会说：“这挺好。我们花两个星期看看能不能超越它。”那会把我逼疯的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. For Tracy, he created a Breaking Bad, yeah. Yeah, and so you get all. on set, and, you know, I have a script I think is great, and I get on the set with the actors, and I'm not saying we're going to change the words, but like, let's figure out what it would really be like and what it wants to be, and, you know, you've got to be open to play in that moment. Yeah. What about, so you wrote and directed a film as well, Lucy in the Sky with Natalie Portman.
对，对，对。为了特雷西，他创造了《绝命毒师》，对吧。对，所以你到了片场，你知道的，我有一个自认为很棒的剧本，我和演员们到了片场，我并不是说我们要改台词，但我们要弄清楚它实际上会是什么样子，它想要成为什么样子，你知道的，你必须对那一刻的即兴发挥保持开放的心态。对。那么，你还自编自导了一部电影，娜塔莉·波特曼主演的《露西在天空》。
Was the film experience anything different than basically just? just a double-length episode for you. And I guess the question behind the question is, is there a desire to do film, or do you see it as just simply arbitrarily a different medium that is every bit consistent with what you're doing on television anyway? And one could argue much more sort of creative control
这段拍电影的经历和基本上只是一集双倍长度的电视剧有什么不同吗？我想这个问题背后的问题是，你对拍电影有渴望吗？还是说你认为它仅仅是一个任意不同的媒介，和你在电视上做的事情完全一致？而且有人可能会认为在电视上有更多的创作控制权
on television. Yeah, I mean, it's its own unique medium, right? And I did like the experience of it. You know, I mean, one of the things that you know, I'm such a use every part of the animal television filmmaker that, you know, sometimes a scene doesn't fit and you're like, I'll use it in episode four,
在电视上。是的，我的意思是，它有它独特的媒介属性，对吧？我确实很喜欢那种体验。你知道的，我是一个把电视电影里的每个部分都榨干的人，有时一个镜头不合适，你会想：“我会在第四集里用它，”
you know, or I'll repurpose this. And then, but with the movie, you're like, there is no episode four. It's either in this movie or it doesn't exist, right? And, you know, whenever I come into a project, my first question is always, what am I taking for granted, right? As a storyteller or a filmmaker, whatever,
你知道的，或者我会重新利用它。但是拍电影的时候，你会想：根本没有第四集。它要么在这部电影里，要么就不存在，对吧？而且，每当我参与一个项目时，我的第一个问题总是：我把什么视为了理所当然？作为一个讲故事的人或电影人，无论是什么，
And with Lucy, I was like, all right, well, this is a movie that's going to be shown in theaters. Well, maybe I'm taking the movie theater itself for granted, the fact that you've got a giant rectangle at the front and all these speakers on the side. And you're taking for granted that you want to use the whole rectangle and all the speakers. But what if this woman goes to space and it's this huge, you know, spiritual experience and the screen is full and the sound is full? And then she comes back down to Earth. We see her in the pickup line, you know, to pick up her kid. and now the image is small and the sound is in the front, right?
拍《露西》的时候，我想：“好吧，这是一部要在电影院上映的电影。”也许我把电影院本身视为了理所当然，比如前面有一个巨大的长方形银幕，两边有那么多扬声器。你理所当然地认为你会想用满整个长方形银幕和所有的扬声器。但如果这个女人去了太空，这是一次巨大的人生精神体验，银幕满满的，声音也满满的。然后她回到了地球。我们在接孩子的队伍里看到她，
But then, you know, she meets your friend, John Hamm, and you guys want to grumble about John some more? I mean, yes, he's all right. He's all right. He's okay. But she meets John, and they have an affair, and so the feelings get big, and the screen opens up, you know. So I'm always looking for those sorts of things.
现在画面变小了，声音也集中在前面，对吧？但随后，她遇到了你的朋友乔恩·哈姆——你们还想再多抱怨乔恩一会儿吗？我是说，对，他挺好的。他挺好的。他还行。但她遇到了乔恩，他们有了一段外遇，于是情绪变得宏大，银幕也随之打开，你知道的。所以我一直在寻找诸如此类的东西。
You know, I think that the structure of a story should reflect the content of a story. What was it about that story that you thought lent itself better to feature as opposed to long form in television? And how do you treat any idea that comes into your head decide whether to write another book based on that idea or actually this is something that could go into
你知道，我认为故事的结构应该反映故事的内容。关于那个故事，有什么吸引你的地方，让你觉得它比电视长篇剧更适合拍成电影？当你脑子里冒出一个想法时，你是如何决定是根据这个想法再写一本书，还是实际上这可以拍成一部有限剧集、一部常规剧集或是一部电影的？部分原因在于你想跟它生活多久。另一方面，你知道的，在电视领域，我们主要是在实时与文化互动。
as a limited series or an ongoing or a feature? Some of it is how long you want to live with it. And the other, you know, TV, we're interacting with the culture mostly in real time. You know, you might be 18 months a year away, like from writing to production, airing, whatever. A book, you know, you might live with for five years, a film you might live with for seven years
从写作到制作、播出等环节，你可能需要经历18个月或一年的时间。一本书，你可能会跟它相处五年；一部电影，从筹备到上映，你可能要跟它相处七年。所以这有点像：这足够有趣吗？这能足够吸引我的注意力吗？里面有足够的内容让我与之相处那么长时间吗？我有足够的话要说吗？有没有什么创意上的“宝贝”是你不得不放手的，
before it hits the screen. And so it's sort of like, is this interesting enough? Is this going to hold my attention enough? Is there enough there for me to live with for that length of time? And do I have enough to say? Were there any sort of creative babies that you had to let go,
那些你爱了很久的想法，有没有哪个让你印象深刻，比如你充满激情地爱了一整年，然后你发现别人也在做类似的事情？你会想：经常这样。或者你只是觉得：它再也无法打动我了。
that ideas that you loved for a long time, do you, anyone that sticks out that you're like, I love this so passionately for a year. And then you read someone else's doing something similar. You're like, all the time. Or you just go, it doesn't really get me anymore.
好吧，我觉得你这是在套取免费的点子啊。我只是说，如果你能……我要说的只是……会是什么，我能制作它吗？对，我的话，总会有一些东西，但话说回来，我还没死呢。你不必具体说出那个实际的点子。对，我想确实有些东西，你知道的，我写过一些我很喜欢的剧本，我写过这本小说《坠落之前》（Before the Fall），
Well, I feel like you're looking for some free ideas here. I'm just saying if you could DMVs. All I'm saying is. What would it be and can I produce it? Yeah, I mean, there's always stuff, but again, I'm not dead yet. You don't have to say specifically the actual idea. Yeah, I think there are things, and there, you know, there's scripts that I wrote that I, that I love, and, you know, I wrote this novel before the fall, and, you know, Sony owned it and I adapted it, I think it's great, but it's expensive, right?
索尼拥有它的版权，我也进行了改编，我觉得它很棒，但它太贵了，你知道的，大概是一部7000万美元的剧情惊悚片，他们现在不拍这种片子了，所以我要么花五年时间撞得头破血流去把它拍出来，要么我想：我还是先等待时机，然后……或者把它拍成限定剧。对，或者把它拍成限定剧，对。那别人的想法呢？
It's like a, you know, $70 million drama thriller, and they don't make those right now, so I could beat my head against a wall for five years trying to get it made, or I could go, I'm going to bide my time, and, and. Or turn it into a limited series. Yeah, or turn it into a limited series, yeah. What about other people's ideas? Let me shoot you my number real quick. Yeah, I'll be great, thanks. Like, are you, you're such anuteur. Do you even spend any time considering other people's work and adapting that?
让我赶紧把我的电话号码发给你。对，太棒了，谢谢。就像，你是如此具有作者风格的人。你甚至会花时间考虑别人的作品并进行改编吗？对，这很有意思。《露西在天空》这个项目不是我原创的。福斯探照灯把它带给我的。那是瑞茜·威瑟斯彭监制的一个剧本。初稿，你知道的，它有点像是一个戏剧化的真实故事，关于那个女宇航员有婚外情，据说穿着尿布跨越美国去绑架……你知道的，这是一个非常小报风格的故事。
Yeah, it's interesting. You know, Lucy in the sky, I did not originate that project. That Fox Searchlight brought that to me. It was a script that Reese Whitherto was producing. The first draft, you know, it's sort of like, dramatization of this true, you know, this tabloid story about this astronaut who has an affair and, you know, drives across the country allegedly in a diaper, you know, to kidnap the, you know, it's a very tabloidy story. And the first script was kind of a diaper joke script and I passed on it.
而第一版剧本有点像是个关于尿布的笑话剧本，我拒绝了。然后，你知道的，他们带着另一个剧本回来了。那个剧本通过魔幻现实主义开始探索她的心理状态，探讨她是如何从那个人变成另一个人的。我觉得这真的很有意思。所以我签了约，并和约翰·亨利·巴特沃思一起开发了它。然后，你知道的，但最后，我觉得如果这个点子是我自己想的并从头开始写，它可能会是一部不同的电影。你知道的，当你拿到一个剧本时，你往往无法超越这个剧本原本的样子。
And then, you know, and then they came back to me with a script that began through magic realism to explore her psychological state of how she went from being that. that one person to being that other person. And I thought that was really interesting. And so I signed on, and I developed it with John Henry Butterworth. And then, you know, but in the end, I feel like if I had had the idea and written it from scratch, it probably would have been a different movie. You know, when you get a script, you kind of can't see past what the script was.
所以，我不知道，这是一部3500万美元的魔幻现实主义宇航员电影，结果证明人们并不想看这种电影。我也不确定他们现在到底想看什么。这真是太碰运气了。非常非常有趣。关于舞台剧或戏剧呢？噢，他来了。你在舞台上忘词过吗，有没有人因此心脏病发作？
So, I don't know, it was a $35 million magic realism astronaut movie, and it turns out people don't want to see those. I'm not sure what they want to see nowadays. It's such a crapshoot. It's really, really interesting. What about stuff for the stage or theater? Oh, here he comes. Did you ever forget a line on stage and anybody ever have a heart attack?
我考虑过。就像我说的，我是个纽约长大的孩子。我父亲曾是个演员。我从小看着各种演出长大，而且，你知道的，这是另一种媒介。这是我还没尝试过的一种艺术形式。对，这是试水更大规模作品的好方法。那么，让我们稍微回到音乐上来。肖恩，听到他也是个歌手，而且还在他的一些剧里唱过歌，你会感到惊讶吗？
I think about it. Like I said, I'm a New York City kid. My dad had been an actor. I grew up going to all the shows and, you know, it's a different medium. It's an animal I haven't tried yet. Yeah, it's a good way to test the waters for, you know, bigger things. And then, so let's go back to music a little bit. Sean, will you be surprised to hear that he's a singer as well
是的。我不知道这个。你还会唱一点。我觉得这算是个大惊喜。我们很想知道观众会对什么感到惊讶。对，你能给我们来一点吗？来一点，来一点。
and has sung on some of his shows? Yes. I didn't know that. You do a little bit of singing. I think that's a big surprise. We like to know what would the audience be surprised about. Yeah, can you give us a little something? A little something, something.
就像“生日快乐”那样，你知道的？今天是肖恩的生日。生日快乐。好的。对，这还是你一直在做的事，对吧？是的，确实。而且，就像我说的，我想成为一名音乐家。
Just like, happy birthday, you know? It's Sean's birthday today. Happy birthday. Okay. Yeah. That's something you still do, yeah? It is, yeah. And, you know, like I said, I wanted to be a musician.
从职业角度来看，这并不太现实。但我找到了一个替代方案，对吧？这就是我试图做的事情：规则是什么，我能破解它吗？你知道的，这始于《冰血暴》第二季，当时我决定想在剧中使用一些翻唱歌曲，这些歌翻唱自科恩兄弟电影中的歌曲，你知道的。所以杰夫·特维迪（Jeff Tweedy）翻唱了
It wasn't really in the cards for me professionally. But I found a workaround, right? That's what I try to do is, what's the system and can I game it? And, you know, it started on season two of Fargo where I decided I wanted songs in the show that were covers of songs from Coen Brothers movies, you know. So Jeff Tweety did a cover
电影《冰血暴》中何塞·费利西阿诺的歌，你知道的，有很多翻唱。然后我想，为什么我不自己做一个呢？于是作曲家杰夫·鲁索和我录制了《去睡觉，你的小宝贝》（Go to Sleep, Your Little Baby），出自《逃狱三王》。
of the Jose Feliciano song from the movie Fargo and, you know, there were a lot, you know, there were a lot of covers. And then I thought, well, why don't I do one? And so Jeff Russo, the composer and I recorded Go to Sleep, your little baby from O'Brother.
然后当我制作《大群》时——那是一部非常超现实的、受漫威启发的剧——我希望歌曲听起来就像配乐一样，我希望音乐能从配乐无缝过渡到歌曲，让人感觉不到任何区别。所以他和我有重新开始录音，就像我在脑子里听到了这个声音，
And then when I made Legion, which was a, you know, a very surreal Marvel inspired show I wanted the songs to sound like score I wanted it to go from score into songs without feeling like there was any difference so he and I just started recording again it's like I hear it in my head
我可以试着向别人解释，或者我们直接把它做出来，你知道的。所以这就是我们最终做的事情，现在我们一直在这么做。这很酷，跟观众们讲讲提案（pitching）的折磨、恐怖或快乐吧，随便你。一个编剧必须……
I could try to explain it to somebody else or we could just do it you know and so that that's what we ended up ended up doing and now we do that that's cool tell the audience a bit the torture the horror or the pleasure, you tell me, of pitching. What a writer has...
好吧，你来解释一下，一个编剧为了让那些写支票的人掏钱，必须做些什么。你基本上得告诉他们接下来会发生什么，对吧？有时候你还得忽悠他们。对。是的，真让人着迷，这种视觉媒介居然仍然植根于口头讲故事的传统中，对吧？
Well, you explain, what a writer has to do to get the people who write the checks to write the check. You've got to basically tell them what's coming, right? And you've got to trick them sometimes. Yeah. Yeah, it's fascinating that this visual medium is still rooted in the oral storytelling tradition, right?
也就是，我走进一个房间，我给你讲一个故事。对。而且如果我很有魅力，你知道的，我的时机把握得很好，你就会说：“噢天哪，这太棒了，我想看这个。”我做过一次提案，我走进房间，然后你知道的，我开始谈论承上启下的话题，也就是从闲聊过渡到提案的环节。我们闲聊了一会儿，我说：“你知道的，我来的路上一直在想怎么把话题转到提案上，我在想你们怎么会喜欢……”
Which is, I walk into a room, I tell you a story. Right. Right. And if I'm charismatic and, you know, I've got good timing, you're going to go, oh my god that's amazing i want to i want to see that right i did one pitch where i went in and you know i started to talk about the segue right the segue of course is the segue from small talk to the pitch right we did the small talk and i was like you know i was thinking over on the way over here about the segue of how i was going to get into the pitch and i was thinking about how are you to like
对，我在想最近我的房子遭了小偷，他们偷了一些吉他，然后我在想，不，也许我该聊聊我昨晚看电视时看到了《条子当道》（Stripes）。我想，我们现在已经没有那种比尔·默瑞式的反英雄了。我又聊了其他几件事。然后到了一定时候，他们意识到：噢，这个过渡本身就是提案，对吧？因为这是一个关于犯罪的反英雄故事，你知道的，所以我的感觉一直是，当你要求别人以任何方式与一部剧产生互动时，无论是大纲还是提案，它必须感觉就像这部剧本身。
yeah i was thinking about how recently my house got broken into and they stole some guitars and then i was thinking, no, maybe I'll talk about how I was watching TV last night and Stripes was on. And I thought, we don't have that kind of Bill Murray anti-hero anymore. And I went through a couple of other things. And then at a certain point, they realized, oh, the segue is the pitch, right? Because it is an anti-hero story about a crime, you know, and so it's, my feeling is always when you're asking someone to interact with the show in any way, whether it's an outline or a pitch, it's got to feel like the show.
所以我每次去片场时都会做发型和化妆测试，现在这已经演变成了一种规模，我会让发型和化妆师带一个摇臂过去，你知道的，因为我会把演员们叫来，我想：我们可不能仅仅通过看穿着衣服的人来浪费一个机会。
and so I do these hair and makeup tests when we get on set where it's grown to this thing where I'll have like a you know a crane on my hair and makeup you know because I'll get the characters in I'm like what it let's not waste an opportunity
我们有机会，你知道的，我们可以把大卫·休里斯、迈克尔·斯图巴和伊万·麦克格雷格聚到一个房间里，去感受他们之间那种化学反应，你知道的，所以我最后把这些东西剪辑在一起，
just by looking at people in clothes right we have an opportunity to like you know let's get let's get David Thulis and Michael Stulbar and you and McGregor in a room and feel like what that dynamic is between them and you know and so I end up cutting these things together
配上音乐，当我把这些展示给他们时，他们就会觉得这就是这部剧将要呈现的感觉，对吧？我太喜欢这样了。对，对，对，因为这已经超越了那种只在房间里进行提案、讲故事的阶段，你需要闪亮的小物件，你需要
with music and when I show it to them that they this is what the show is going to feel like right? I love that right yeah yeah yeah because it's not I mean we were kind of past the point of talking just going in the room and pitching telling a story you need shiny objects you need to
让他们兴奋起来，你需要，你知道的，精剪预告片（sizzle reels）或者类似的东西，这对演员来说太棒了，因为他们可以在没有任何压力的情况下提前体验角色一两天，而且这也能唤醒剧组人员，对吧？他们会想：“哦，我们在发型和化妆测试里就在推轨道车了。”
excite them and you need to like you know sizzle reels or whatever or something but it's great for the actors because they get to put the skin on without any pressure right for a day or two and and then wakes the crew up right they're like oh we're pushing a dolly in the in the hair and makeup test.
就像我在铺设轨道，我们是在动真格的。对。你知道的。其实我们去年在拍我们的电影时就这么做过，我拍的那部电影，我们在城外进行了所有的摄像机测试，只有我和布拉德利（Bradley）、马蒂·利巴蒂克（Maddy Libatik）还有其他人，我们出去白天黑夜地拍了好几天。我们去拍了所有这些东西。
Like, I'm laying track, and we're doing this for real. Yeah. Yeah. You know. We did that, actually, on our film last year on this movie that I did, and we did all this camera testing here in the city outside, just me and Bradley and Maddie Libatik and guys, and we went out and shot for a couple days during the day at night. We went and shot all this stuff.
最后布拉德利把它们剪辑在一起，做出了这段视频，放给电影公司看，里面配了音乐和发生过的事情。这真是……A，对他们很好；但B，真的，对我们来说，它在我们开始之前就帮我们理清了这部电影的语言。对，你能感受到它。对，而且，这真的非常有帮助。对，肯定的。
And Bradley ended up cutting it together and putting together this reel that he was showing the studio and cut it with music and with stuff that happened. And it was so. A, it was great for them, but B, really, for us, it really started to, it taught us the language of the film before we started. Yeah, you get to feel it. Yeah, and it was, it was really, really helpful. Yeah, for sure.
对，确实如此。我发现，你知道的，这成了一个内部的销售文件，让他们觉得：“看看这家伙为我们制作了什么。”我们在拍《异形：地球》，你会觉得自己好像在看一部《异形》电影，持续了四分钟左右。这太酷了。如果我们让你离开却没有给你一个机会和肖恩讨论你愿意提及的程度，那我们就太不称职了。
Yeah, it is, it is. I find it, you know, and it becomes a sales document for them internally of like, look what this guy's making for us, you know. We're making Alien Earth, and you feel like you're watching, you know, an alien movie for four minutes or whatever it is. Yeah, it's cool. We would be criminal if we're, we let you go without giving you an opportunity to discuss with Sean what to the extent you're
如果你不愿意，我们可以剪掉。星际迷航到底怎么了？你参与《星际迷航》的项目是不是要告一段落了？对，因为你本来应该编写并执导它，对吧？是这样的吗？我确实参与了。我在拍完《露西在天空》之后加入了，我想：“哦，我挺喜欢拍电影这事的。我想再拍一部，但我想也许我想尝试一些更大一点的题材。”
comfortable. We can cut it if you're not. What happened with Star Trek and will it, will, will your participation with Star Trek be coming at an end? Yeah, because you're supposed to write and direct it, right? Was it? I did. I signed on, you know, after Lucy in the sky, I thought, oh, I like this movie thing. I'd like to do another one, but I think maybe I'd like to try something a little bigger. and you know it's all franchises and i thought yeah but everything's war right star wars is war and marvel is war and but star trek isn't war star trek is exploration right it's people solving problems by being smarter than the other guy like the best movie from the best moment from star trek is in wrath of con where where shatner puts on his reading glasses and like lowers the shields on the other ship it costs like 45 cents right right but it's like you see oh he's smarter than con he's yeah And so I went in, I talked to Paramount, I sold them this original idea, it wasn't Chris Pine, it wasn't anything, I wrote it, they said we love it, let's prep it, we were, you know, we were, I was going to move to Australia, we were booking stages, whatever, and then, you know, as happens in Hollywood, Jim Giannopoulos, who was running the studio at the time, he's like, I'm going to bring in somebody else under me, and they're going to take over the film studio. and the first thing they did was kill the original Star Trek movie because they said, well, how do we know people are going to like it?
你知道的，全都是特许经营宇宙，我想：“对，但全都是战争，星战是战争，漫威也是战争，但星际迷航不是战争，星际迷航是探索，对吧？那是人们通过比对方更聪明来解决问题，就像《星际迷航》里最好的时刻是在《可汗怒吼》中，威廉·夏特纳戴上老花镜，下令降低对方飞船的护盾，那只花了大约45美分，对吧？但你会看到：‘哦，他比可汗更聪明。’他就是这样。”所以我去跟派拉蒙谈了，我向他们推销了这个原创点子，不是克里斯·派恩，不是别的什么，我写好了，他们说：“我们很喜欢，我们开始筹备吧。”我们当时，你知道的，我准备搬去澳大利亚，我们在预订片场，诸如此类。然后，你知道的，正如好莱坞经常发生的那样，当时管理制片厂的吉姆·詹纳opoulos说：“我要在我手下引入另一个人，他们将接管电影制片厂。”而他们做的第一件事就是砍掉了最初的《星际迷航》电影，因为他们说：“好吧，我们怎么知道人们会喜欢它呢？”
Like, you know, shouldn't we do a transition movie from Chris Pine, play it safe, you know, whatever? And so it kind of went away, but, you know, I do. I mean, I talked to David Ellison recently, and I was like, you still haven't made a Star Trek movie. I'm just saying it's in there. I love it. Yeah, it's sort of like with all this new ownership and administration over there,
就像，你知道的，我们难道不应该拍一部克里斯·派恩的过渡电影，稳妥一点，随便什么都行吗？所以这个想法有点不了了之了，不过，你知道的，我确实。我是说，我最近和大卫·埃里森聊过，我说你还没拍过《星际迷航》电影呢。我只是觉得它就在那儿。我喜欢它。是的，就像现在那边有所有这些新的所有权和管理层一样，
I guess you can just pick up the phone and say, hey guys want to dust this off? Right, right. You just wait five minutes in Hollywood for everybody to get a new job and then go pitch the same stuff again. Sean, what are you saying? Nothing.
我想你只要拿起电话说，嘿伙计们，想把这个重新拿出来拍吗？对，对。在好莱坞，你只要等上五分钟，等每个人都换了新工作，然后再去推销同样的东西就行了。肖恩，你在说什么？没什么。
You know, I mean, I don't know if you guys feel the same way but to some degree you really have to declare this is my next thing, this is all I want to do, all I want to think about, and then you can move the mountain, right? For me, I've got more alien earth, I could make more Fargo, like it's a little, little, it's more like, well, you know, what I learned from Ridley Scott, you know, who I got to know some, you know, he'll develop three movies at the same time and he'll say to Sony, I'm going to
你知道，我的意思是，我不知道你们是否有同感，但在某种程度上，你真的必须宣告这就是我的下一个项目，这就是我唯一想做的事，唯一想思考的事，然后你就能移山，对吧？对我来说，我有更多的《异形：地球》，我可以拍更多的《冰血暴》，这有点像，更像是，嗯，你知道的，我从雷德利·斯科特那里学到的，你知道的，我有幸了解他一些，你知道的，他会同时开发三部电影，他会告诉索尼，我要
make the Fox movie unless you guys, you know what I mean? So you kind of have to try to get them to play your game as opposed to play a little leverage there. Right, right. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Well, you've certainly done your part with that. Keep it, keep it coming. Please, Noah. It's, it's an incredible body of work already and um are you even 40 yet i mean you know i am i'm older than 40 well um you've uh you've got it's just impressive it's so broad and it's so diverse and it's so everything about it is just it's really and the degree of difficulties high on this stuff you're not you're not the novel and the the fact that you write novels and like the i know all these novels that these guys will never read yeah i am i am going to start i am going to buy some of your books
拍那部福克斯的电影，除非你们，你知道我的意思吗？所以你得试着让他们按你的规则玩，而不是去搞点筹码。对，对。嗯哼。嗯哼。好吧，在这方面你确实尽力了。继续，继续保持。拜托，诺亚。这已经是一部令人难以置信的作品了，而且呃你还不到40岁吧，我是说，我知道我，我比40岁大，嗯，呃，你，你真的是太令人印象深刻了，它太广泛了，太多元了，它的一切都真的是，而且这玩意的难度系数很高，你不是，你不是写小说，还有你写小说的事实，比如我知道这些小说这些家伙永远不会读，对，我，我打算开始，我打算买一些你的书
Well, I appreciate that. Even if they're just on your shelf, it's meaningful to them. No, no, no, he reads these things. It's a very surprising element of Will Arnett. This guy knocks down books like Reese Witherspoon. Yeah, so I'm going to check out. All right, pal, well, thank you for doing this very much. I'm glad we got this done.
好吧，我很感激。即使它们只是摆在你的书架上，对它们来说也很有意义。不，不，不，他会读这些东西。这是威尔·阿奈特非常令人惊讶的一面。这家伙啃书的速度跟瑞茜·威瑟斯彭一样快。是的，所以我要去看看。好了，伙计，非常感谢你做这些。我很高兴我们完成了这个。
I'm glad you had time to squeeze this in your busy, busy schedule. Thanks, guys. I really appreciate it. So nice to meet you. Yeah, nice to meet you, Noah. Thanks, man. You too, guys. Talk soon, man.
我很高兴你能在繁忙的日程中挤出时间来做这件事。谢谢你们，伙计们。我真的很感激。很高兴认识你们。是的，很高兴认识你，诺亚。谢谢，伙计。你们也是，伙计们。回头聊，伙计。
There goes Noah Holly. I mean He's something else, man What an impressive guy I like to think I work hard You know But I don't What are you talking about
诺亚·霍利走了。我的意思是，他真是与众不同，伙计。多么令人印象深刻的人。我总觉得我很努力，你知道的。但我其实没有。你在说什么？
You're tired at two Yeah But I worked so hard until two Yeah I mean You like to think that you work hard And can I just say And I want you to be honest
你两点就累了。对。但我努力工作到两点。对。我的意思是，你总觉得自己很努力。我能说吗？我希望你能诚实
As honest as you can be Okay I'm ready How many golf games Do you have scheduled This week Including yesterday I will be playing
尽可能地诚实。好吧，我准备好了。这周你有多少场高尔夫球局？包括昨天在内，我要打
Wednesday Thursday Friday Okay But I work during the round, as you know. I'm returning emails and texts all the way through it. And I'm usually knocking down one of these goddamn things before I get out there. And then I make a more phone call when I get home. Sorry, we're getting in the way of your golf. This fucking podcast, man.
周三、周四、周五。好吧，但如你所知，我在打球期间也在工作。我一直在回复电子邮件和短信。而且我通常在出门前就能搞定这其中的一件破事。然后我回家后还要再打个电话。抱歉，我们打扰你打高尔夫了。这该死的播客，伙计。
It's no good for my golf game. By the way, Sean, you know what? My favorite thing about J.B. is sometimes we're playing golf and he won't pull out of his phone. But you'll see him all of a sudden he'll just wander off talking. into his apple, into his watch. And my wrist. And he's talking to his wrist, and he's like, yeah, we'll get them to send it. Tell them, we'll look at it the thing tomorrow. Period.
这对我的高尔夫球技没好处。顺便说一句，肖恩，你知道吗？我最喜欢杰比的一点是，有时我们在打高尔夫球，他就是不肯放下手机。但你会看到他突然就自顾自地走开，一边走一边对着他的苹果手表说话。对着我的手腕。他在对着自己的手腕说话，他说，对，我们会让他们发货的。告诉他们，我们明天会看看那东西。句号。
New paragraph. Why don't we try to do an episode of SmartList while you're playing golf? You know, because I don't play that much. I work a lot. No, but why you're on the course, just bring your phone. Why don't we go to Hawaii? Why don't we go to Hawaii and play around a golf?
新段落。为什么我们不在你打高尔夫的时候录一集《SmartList》呢？你知道的，因为我不常打球。我工作很忙。不，但你在球场上的时候，把手机带上就行了。为什么我们不去夏威夷？为什么我们不去夏威夷打一场高尔夫？
We've been invited and, you know, we're actually, to be honest, we're all a little bit too busy to do that i know you know we're all we should we should we should we i think and i know again we should talk about this privately but we might as well do it here we've talked about it we should go back and do some shows some live shows yeah why not start get up back get back out on the road yeah yeah why wouldn't we yeah at the very at the minimum we should go and and and be on stage somewhere and doing it in front of a live audience why don't we do it like at the end of next year okay we could could we do the spring or no is this spring off limits for us i'm gonna be in new york can you
我们受到邀请了，而且，说实话，我们其实都太忙了，没法去那儿，我知道，你知道，我们都，我们应该，我们应该，我们应该，我觉得，我也知道，我们应该私下里讨论这个，但我们不妨现在就在这里讨论。我们已经讨论过了，我们应该回去做一些演出，一些现场演出。对，为什么不开始，重新出发，重新上路。对，对，为什么不呢？对，最起码，我们应该去某个地方登台演出，在现场观众面前表演。为什么我们不在明年年底左右做这件事呢？好吧，我们可以，我们能定在春天吗？还是说春天对我们来说是禁区？我要去纽约，你能
hold on one second yeah no shoney when you done the play i'm doing the play uh january i love that we're doing this in real time i know do the play january to april like january 3rd basically february 3rd i say we do like pre-summer so it's nice out that's what i'm saying is that we can yeah oh yeah so it's not so cold sort of like september we were going to go we were going you know i might have a little bit of work uh as well well i know you are you're not planning on doing any work will you done i am i am i might You might, I might, I might, you're going to pack it in now? You know what, we can, we can, we can, we can, we can keep talking about it.
等一下。对，不，肖尼，你演话剧的时候——我要演话剧，呃，一月。我喜欢我们实时进行这个对话。我知道，演话剧从一月到四月，基本上是一月三日到二月三日。我建议我们选在夏天之前，天气好的时候。这就是我说的，我们可以，哦，对，这样就不会太冷了。就像九月份我们本打算去，我们本打算，你知道的，我可能也会有一点工作。好吧，我知道你有，你没打算做什么工作吧，will？我做，我做，我可能——你可能，我可能，你可能，你现在要把这事搁置了吗？你知道吗，我们可以，我们可以，我们可以继续讨论它。
Like, we don't, we don't, we can make a decision, yeah. Bye, the end of the year. I know, God, no, no, Sean, what was yours going to do? Mine was, we can just talk about it, we don't have to decide now, we can go day by day. Or, you know what, better still, we just play it by year. Oh, a three-by-bye-bye. Hey. Triple-bye.
就像，我们不用，我们不用，我们可以做个决定，对吧？到年底。我知道，天哪，不，不，肖恩，你刚才想说什么？我的意思是，我们可以讨论一下，我们不用现在就决定，我们可以走一步算一步。或者，你知道更妙的是什么吗？我们就随遇而安。哦，一个三连拜。嘿。三倍再见。
Pass. Smartless. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
过。Smartless。Smartless。Smartless由贝内特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗伯·阿姆贾夫（Rob Armjarf）100%有机纯手工制作。Smartless。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。